do
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
don't blame me when i left scotland this
morning the sun
was baking hot and the ground
added dry by the time i got to london
the heavens had opened thunder and
lightning
and here's me dressed for the beach well
i'll just have to make the best of it as
will
you because this is going to be a
cracking show
are you filled with the olympic spirit
what olympics who even knew
the olympics in tokyo had started
and talk about bringing politics into
sports
russia aren't even allowed to
participate
i'll be discussing more in my monologue
and how does it feel to be free after a
week of freedom
in england though not yet in
scotland i am in the land of the mask
less
but tomorrow i have to return and dub
myself up
because well hey the coronavirus
recognizes a scotland england border
even if nobody else does and
is gallane maxwell a just a poor
little woman much put upon by her
overbearing partner
jeffrey epstein or is she up to her neck
in sex and spying i know which
of the alternatives i prefer
and we'll be talking about american
politics
and british politics american media and
british media
fasten your seat belts it's going to be
a bumpy ride
because you are on the mother
of all talk shows
radio sputnik we speak your language
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free
[Music]
george galloway this
is radio sputnik
welcome to the mother of all talk shows
you can listen to us
in crystal clarity in the washington dc
era on 105.5
i said era by mistake i meant
area but in the trump era
the president of the united states
himself
no less was listening on 105.5
fm to us in the washington dc
area and in the rest of the united
states
we are on am from coast to coast from
burning city
to burning city now not burning
actually literally but metaphorically
and we'll be talking
about the extreme weather conditions
from
siberia to here in central london
in the course of the show but if
you are in the listening mode you can
listen throughout the world
on sputniknews.com
all over the world thanks to al gore and
the
invention of the internet and speaking
of
al gore athams you if you are
watching us and half a million people do
every single week now you can
share if you're on facebook with every
friend that you've got
in the world because algorithm is
constantly trying
to keep us down shadow banning and
actual banning and outright banning
sometimes i make tweets that get 10
000 people's attention
likes retweets sometimes i tweet clips
they get a hundred thousand views
and then and i can usually predict them
in advance
i tweet and get only a couple of hundred
i send out a clip and get only a couple
of thousand so don't tell me that the
big tech
social media oligarchs are not watching
us closely
i know that they are but if you're
watching
on my facebook please share now
you can also watch on rt's multiple
facebook pages you can watch on my
youtube and do subscribe if you
are doing so and i'm still waiting for
that award
that i'm supposed to get supposed to
have got
many weeks ago from youtube for
achieving more than 100 000
subscribers you can watch on twitter
which an astounding number of you
are going up every single week in leaps
and
bounds you can watch on instagram
usually but not tonight because
my missus had to stay at home because of
the
extreme good weather at home
i gave her the night off but you can
also watch on my telegram channel and i
really stress this to you
given the activities of the
aforementioned algorithm
you'd be better to get on my telegram
channel
if not now then in the next day or two
because in the end
that may be the last redoubt
now are you watching the tokyo olympics
many people don't even know that they
are on
in fact we're running a poll on it are
you watching the
tokyo olympics a yes b no c
i've got a lot not c they should be
cancelled
canceled for one of several reasons
no doubt they say that we should keep
politics
out of sport although some of the people
that say that most loudly
are amongst those that have ensured that
russia
are not participating at this year's
olympic games well rather the russian
olympic committee is
but it's got to call itself rock roc
it's not allowed to fly the russian flag
the proximate reason is doping
allegations indeed the finding of doping
offenses but of course russia isn't the
only
country that has been guilty of that
have they but russia has been kept out
of the olympic games
the reason i didn't even know that the
olympic games had started
comes as a surprise to me having watched
them
every four years on the bbc in
kind of multi-screen watching every
sport
that's going on there i now discover
that the bbc has been
out bid for television coverage
of the olympic games and now is
restricted to
only one sport at a time because
the discovery channel about which we're
going to discover
much more in the years to come
has outbid the bbc and will allow the
bbc
a license only to show one sport
at a time and only on bbc one
of course on the discovery channel you
can watch all the olympic sports
but only some of them free to view
the rest of them you'll have to pay for
and yet we were told i was told
in the british parliament that the
olympic games like the fa cup final
would continue to be a people's
sport and continue to be covered for
free
well i say free but we are paying
through the nose
for the bbc in the first place so one of
the reasons for doing so
just disappeared you can no longer watch
the olympic games
in total on the bbc so why are we paying
this license fee all kinds of issues
arise but of course many japanese people
the overwhelming majority of japanese
people
don't want these olympic games to be
happening
at all because they have a serious
coronavirus problem
and people flying in from all around the
world
to be involved in an olympic games
was not quite what they thought fighting
covert 19
was so it's all shaping
up to be something of a fiasco
you may have a point of view on that i'd
like to
hear it and you can vote in our poll
now and my first guest this evening
is about a subject that is close to my
heart
forgive me if you've heard me say this
before
but i was engaged in mortal combat right
up until the point
of his death with robert maxwell
the greatest thief of the 20th century
who owned an empire of newspapers which
periodically produced would be a mild
word
often libel slandered defamed me
across their multiple titles
the chief hatchet man for robert maxwell
at the time was one alistair campbell
and alastair campbell penned an assault
on me
on the front page of the daily mirror
the daily record the sunday people the
european
uh i could hardly remember now
the number of titles in which this
attack on me was launched
by robert maxwell through his hacks
like alistair campbell it came as
well the germans have a word for it
schadenfreude to me when
all of these hatchet men and women woke
up one morning
to discover that the proprietor for whom
they lied so assiduously
had stolen their pensions one or two
good people
like the editor of this program had his
pension stolen too
and i'm sorry about that he's having to
continue working
even though he's 93. his
pension was stolen but the hatchet men's
pension was stolen too and they had to
pay me
a very very substantial sum in damages
for that particular attack but robert
maxwell
cheapened and coarsened and well frankly
subverted british public life for many
decades
including an ill-starred four years in
which he served in the british
parliament
six years in fact 1964
to 1970. during which period
he became the chairman of the catering
committee
and promptly stole all their silverware
and their best
wine and i'm really not making that up
robert maxwell was brought down
in part by me in parliament
under privilege accusing him
of sandre offenses which
all came to pass and much much more
prior to that no one could
name and shame robert maxwell for his
multi-furious crimes and misdemeanors
because he simply would have sledge
hammered you into the ground
with the libel laws if you had sought to
do so
but he didn't reckon on me and
parliamentary privilege so
i was at war for many years with robert
maxwell
and thus i have followed the ill-starred
career
of gillane maxwell ever since
imagine my surprise when galen maxwell
also turned out to be someone up to
their neck in
espionage and sexual uh
crimes and misdemeanors she's now
on trial for at least some of those
crimes and misdemeanors
but my first guest this evening kirby
summers is going to tell you things
that will make your hair stand on
end as i say it's now freedom week
in england for the uh time being
at least one can go around mask less
one can go into restaurants without
wearing
a mask one can do all kinds of things
that it feels
i haven't been able to do for
many years though it's only been a year
and
a bit it has been hell
in britain under the coronavirus
and most people are extremely happy
that they are now freed from some but
not all
of the restrictions but is it going to
work and is the price that we're being
asked to pay
for the ending of the lockdown and the
lifting of the restrictions
such an affront to civil liberty
in britain that is not a price worth
paying
many people feel that way the issue
of covered passports is
moving thousands of people according to
the polls
most people support them i get that
but there are millions of people who
think
that the state coming into your
health records is one thing perhaps
one thing too far but when tesco
or sainsbury can have
access to your health pass
can have access to your state of health
that may be a bridge too far
when you're being asked to provide
proof of vaccination when you don't
agree with the vaccination and
may very well be excluded
from the bread aisle in the supermarket
if you cannot prove you've been double
jabbed
that's taking us on very thin ice
indeed isn't it
and the double jab which i have had
and strongly urge everyone to have
isn't turning out to be
as great a level of protection
as i for one had hitherto imagined
same goes for piers morgan perhaps the
greatest
proselytizer for lockdown and
vaccination
in this whole country he's writing from
his sick bed
in the newspapers this morning and says
that he almost died over the last week
or two
of coronavirus even though he's double
jabbed so is the vaccination
turning out to be as efficacious
as most of us had believed and
hoped i'll be talking to dr ranjit brah
about that very subject in the course of
this
show i'll be talking to about the
extremities of the weather map
in the world today it is
now undeniable that something
big is happening with climate
here on planet earth the heat map
of the world in the 1970s
is incomparable to the heat map of the
world
in a 2019
another boiling hot summer the
flooding in china in germany
in belgium was so extreme
that one had to rub one's eyes in order
to believe them germany one of the most
developed
and well organized countries in the
world
had people and things being swept down
the highways so extreme was the flooding
there belgium
not quite so well organized suffered
even more badly and as i told you
london is flooding right at this moment
i never felt more silly wearing a straw
hat
when i see people with umbrellas blown
inside out as torrential rain
thunder and lightning strikes the
capital
of the united kingdom we'll be talking
to a very considerable expert
about that later and of course no show
is complete without the coolest of
american
cats garland nixon will be talking
about politics and media stateside
and the irrepressible patrick christie's
will be doing the same here in the
studio
about british politics and british
media but here's my first question of
the night
on georgia's general knowledge on this
day in 1965
bob dylan was booed at the newport folk
festival
for going electric what was the first
song
he played a maggie's farm
be like a rolling stone or c
mr tambourine man answers
after the short break
radio sputnik
[Music]
gosh darn how do you get this thing to
work
ah did that one
is it it this one here gosh
was this thing built in america jeez
kamala would you get in here
i can't get the uh gosh darn wireless to
work
you know i can't answer questions joe
when i'm laughing
i'm trying to uh listen to that
scottish guy on the wireless the uh
the galloway fella oh joe you're so
funny
[Music]
i've been pressing this red button on
and
off and on and off heck i can't get it
to work
uh hello biden residents
mr president be advised we have executed
the airstrike on syria
that's just great uh how long until it
gets delivered i'm
starving
sputnik has been launched to give you a
closer look at everything happening in
the world
radio sputnik telling the untold
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
on this day in 1965 bob dylan was booed
at the newport
folk festival for going electric what
was the first song he played it was
of course maggie's farm it's hard to
imagine
maggie's farm being performed other than
with
electrics are you watching the tokyo
olympics
yes 21 of you surprisingly high number
actually
uh no 69 percent of you
see they should be cancelled ten percent
of you
get voting now on my twitter feed
now as i said earlier
jeffrey epstein was a monster
doesn't mean he committed suicide
doesn't mean he wasn't moderate
and if he was murdered it's murder most
foul because
he was a helpless man in a u.s prison
cell
when he was murdered if he was murdered
i think his suicide came as a very great
surprise
to him more than anyone else
he's no longer here at least we must
assume
he's no longer here to answer the
charges
which remain at large against him
of being not just a monster a
sexual predator a pedophile preying on
very young girls about doing so
in the context of a political
and financial blackmail scheme
by which people allowed him to use very
large sums of
their money or he
might release evidence he had garnered
of their sexual crimes
he had an accomplice an apprentice
a partner in crime that much is clear
and her name was galen maxwell
the daughter of the aforementioned
monster
robert maxwell it is the murkiest of
waters
as murky as the waters in which robert
maxwell
himself perished after he fell
off the back of his yacht called
lady galen of course he may have been
pushed
off the back of that yacht i have my
suspicions about that now kirby summers
is an investigative journalist and an
author
of note who's been following this whole
murky twisted tale as closely as anyone
on the planet and i'm glad to say she
joins us now
from the united states kirby uh
thanks for joining us on the mother of
all talk shows
first break thank you for having me
bring us up to date
on how the galen maxwell legal
proceedings
are going would you absolutely i want to
thank you for reminding everyone that
this is an espionage case
um i want to preface what i'm going to
say about
gulen maxwell by reminding people that
alexander acosta um was told to back off
that epstein belonged to intelligence so
if we can say that
about jeffrey epstein we can certainly
say that about glenn maxwell
um the the other thing that i want to
get into before i bring you up to date
is that um while people look at glenn
maxwell
as being jeffrey epstein's
shadow and his partner that is not the
way his victims
or her victims look at her in fact
um bradley edwards who represents
many of the victims has said that it was
glenn maxwell who began this whole thing
that without her epstein would not have
done what he did
that the first victims that were
procured were
were actually brought in by galen
maxwell
so what she has been trying to do in her
case
is well is is many things right she has
been
she wants a get out of free a jail card
really is
is bottom line what she wants and to
that end
she uh has requested to be allowed out
of jail five
town times and she's been denied
she continues to insist through her
attorneys
that the non-prosecution agreement given
to jeffrey epstein
in 2008 by alexander acosta
should protect her but this is incorrect
because it is not the right jurisdiction
nor is it the right date because galen
is being held in jail for crimes
committed
in 1994 through 1997
and then the fourth victim came in with
crimes committed in 2001
and then of course the jurisdiction took
it out of the state of florida
and took it let's say into new mexico
and new york
and even in london but she continues to
insist that hey
i have a non-prosecution agreement
please let me out of
jail uh judge nathan has not agreed to
date
i do not think that a judge nathan is
going to
allow her to get out of jail she has
also been trying to garner
a lot of sympathy to this end
remember that photo did you get to see
it with her
trying to say that she had a black eye
yeah
yeah well that was sort of like
when your your skin is very thin and
she's going to be
60 this december um that's sort of like
a skin
uh discoloration it's not really a
bruise but she has been making a lot of
noise
saying that her health is not well and
that she
is not sleeping and it's one thing after
another the woman knows nothing but to
complain
um she is doing this i believe because
she is trying to still get out of jail
so as far as are we going to
actually see a real criminal
case my answer is no i do not believe
we're going to see anything
normal now don't forget it's november so
it's just a couple of months away
i think one of two things will happen
and you tell me if you agree
with me because i think you have a
really good gut instinct on this
the first thing that could happen is um
well let me back up one step so doug
band
who was bill clinton's
right hand man has been cooperating with
the prosecution
and that's very interesting because it
sort of sets
the stage if you will for what glenn
maxwell
ultimately will want and that is to have
a closed door proceeding meaning that it
is a spy case right this is not just a
as horrible as it sounds a a
sex trafficking case that includes
minors
that's horrible by itself but this is
also a spy case
which means that there's a lot of
information that
in my opinion the united states cannot
afford to
be made public as well as the state of
israel
because in my opinion i believe that
jeffrey epstein and gelane maxwell and
this is based on my
20 years of knowing about this case and
my research
have worked for both the united states
and uh israel so i think that that's a
possibility that
and and it was actually used by um in
the iran contra
case where
names were being threatened to be used
and suddenly they had to have the closed
not
and they will have available postpone so
if the true
that i just said might happen which are
you more inclined to uh the first one
uh the the idea that
uh guillain maxwell the daughter of
robert maxwell
could be involved in espionage on behalf
of
israel and the united states would be
the least
surprising news i'll hear this year
the allegations i made
against robert maxwell in parliament
under parliamentary privilege
uh included uh the allegation that he
was an
agent of israeli intelligence
that he had betrayed the whereabouts in
london
of the brave israeli jewish
whistleblower
motherhood so that he could be kidnapped
and held in solitary confinement for
almost
20 years and that allegation was
confirmed
by the burial of robert maxwell
on the mount of olives by
three serving and former
israeli prime ministers five
serving and former presidents of
israel and three serving
and former heads of the mossad
israeli intelligence so my allegations
are regarded as having been proved on
the day
of his funeral so the idea that his
daughter would be involved in espionage
for israel is buttressed of course
by the extraordinarily close
relationship
between her and epstein and
erhud barak the former prime minister
of israel who was a guest of
epstein on multiple occasions
am i right yes absolutely one hundred
percent
in fact was given his
own apartment at 301 east 66th street
and for your listeners who are not
familiar with that building
that epstein was was actually given a
lot of property
this building is a couple of steps away
from his
main mansion on 71st street on the upper
east side of manhattan
and was given a an apartment on the 10th
floor
whenever he was in town that's where he
would stay
his um security guards would kind of
congregate
in the lobby to the annoyance of
everyone who was there uh but yeah
barack uh spent a good deal of time with
epstein
and and with maxwell but speaking of um
so before you go on yeah what might have
been the attraction
uh for the former prime minister
of israel in hanging out with uh
jeffrey epstein well i mean you and i
both know what it is
but also it is alleged by virginia
giffrey who has
also said the same thing about prince
andrew
that uh jeffrey epstein and delane
maxwell
uh coerced her into having intimate
relationships with
barack wow oh you had not heard that
i hadn't and that's a vision i'm going
to try and
uh wipe from my mind let me
though ask you there are people who say
uh that this uh je frey
is an increasingly discredited witness
who changes our story and
gives information that turns out later
to be
untrue about her own life and so on
uh are are you still confident in
her bona fides as it were i am 100
percent confident that virginia gerfrey
if she said that jeffrey epstein and
galen maxwell
asked her to sleep with prince andrew on
three separate occasions
i believe her to be saying 100 the truth
i have known virginia uh initially
through
uh twitter for close to two years now
and um she's
a a very kind and loving person despite
every horrible thing that has happened
to her remember what happened to her
happened a very long time ago she was a
young
teenager 14 year old teenager on the
streets
and she had been in sort of like this
institutional care
she had run away from that and before
falling
into the clutches of galen maxwell
who plucked her out of donald trump's
mar-a-lago in florida
she was sort of in the clutches of
another uh trafficker so she did not
you know she was very young she was not
given an opportunity to go to school
like normal people because
when she tried to do that at the age of
was when she was working at mar-a-lago
i'm sorry at the age of 15.
i've got that wrong um galen maxwell was
driving by
she spotted her she made a beeline
toward her
the girls i don't know if you're aware
of this the girls that were
targeted by both galen maxwell and
jeffrey epstein
had a very similar look they were slight
they were blonde and they were very
young teenagers
and and virginia always looked younger
than her years
so at 15 she looked 13.
she looked and so this when you when
people look and say
oh well glenn maxwell was in love with
jeffrey epstein
and they were a couple no they were
never a couple in my opinion and in the
opinion of
the um victims they were never holding
hands they never kissed they didn't
sleep in the same bed
um and it is it's really is is galen
blonde and thin and is she 14
no no that's uh all true uh
now uh let me uh let me pose what
for me is the more i mean you're right
to say
monstrous as those sexual allegations
all are uh the
palin to insignificance
compared to the real crimes that may
well
have been being committed over many
years
of the deliberate entrapment
for blackmail of very powerful
political people and the deliberate
entrapment for blackmail for financial
reasons of some of the richest men in
america none of that is going on trial
in november is it
no it's not um
and look i believe that
leslie wexner and leon black in
my opinion and i know about them
personally in my own life
i i think that um i think you know what
an intelligence agency does
right so for example let's take harvard
university as an example
with the mk ultra program of the 1950s
with the cia
what the cia did in that instance
was they created about a hundred shell
corporations
the hundred shell corporations were each
funded
they then in turn contacted let's say
harvard and some psychiatric hospitals
and
other universities and they said hey
we're performing some studies some
scientific studies so we want to fund
this
program and so that this the end
user let's call it harvard did not know
where the money was coming from did not
know it was a cia
assignment that they were conducting i
looked
at leslie wexner and at leon black
as a funnel which funneled money
into the jeffrey epstein gulen maxwell
trafficking ring and kept it going on
behalf
of the us and israel
yeah i suppose i'm asking were they
doing this
because they're perverts
or in order to entrap people for
the purposes of financial stroke
political
blackmail no they were doing this for
political um to to
stay in power uh this is all to
enhance and retain the power of israel
enhance and retain the power of the
uh people who have been purchased and
paid for in the united states and in
countries all over the
world it wasn't just limited to
politicians or
wealthy men that lived in the united
states
you have your own problem there in the
uk with prince
andrew this happened you know we they he
was also connected
with um saudi arabia this happened all
over the world they had
andres pastrana who even had the saudi
passport
that's right i mean so he's not limited
yeah a u.s citizen jewish
yes working for israel had a saudi
passport
yeah but we can thank um
we can thank that gun runner uh
what is his name he was very big also
with iran
contra
thank you yes because he was
he was someone who came into jeffrey
epstein's life very early on he was
also as you probably know in robert
maxwell's life
he was big time he saw the yacht
the lady galen off which robert maxwell
fell used to be owned by the
saudi gun runner adnan khashoggi
no it was uh actually his his
nephew made it for
for maxwell now what's interesting about
that is
he he made it it was almost supposed to
be for himself but he
he mirrored exactly khashoggi's
yacht which had state of the art
satellite equipment
that allowed him when he was going to do
business
he did in the same way as jeffrey
epstein he also had sex slaves
he would take his yacht into the water
and and his yacht ended up with donald
trump
later on in in future years uh but then
he would take it out into international
waters
he would have the young girls on board
he would then
if the if the young girls and he would
he would have it also
you know if there were pinhole cameras
in the bedrooms
if if blackmail didn't work or if if
just they did not want to do business
with him uh
he would blackmail them there was no way
to say no so that
robert maxwell's yacht which was built
for him
by khashoggi's uh nephew
was built with the same all of the same
kind of like jazzed up equipment um so
that he can
he too can conduct business on
international waters
and always stay in touch let's say even
with the stock market right and this is
a long time ago we're talking about the
19 mid 1980s yeah yeah
yeah long before technology made that
possible for for your everyday
millionaire
never mind billionaire media
magnate but i'm right in saying that
none of these
uh political issues will emerge in the
courtroom in november which brings me
back
to your dichotomy that you posed earlier
they will almost certainly in my view
close the doors on this trial for
for the very reason that
the risk of
some of this becoming common currency
in a courtroom in the united states is
too great for them
that's why it will be a closed door
trial is not right
that's what i think i also um know that
let's say for example you you brought up
virginia duffray
so she's tweeted every now and then that
gulen maxwell is such a selfish woman
that she will give up everyone including
prince
andrew frankly um and so that that would
be another
way for her to maneuver
this case out of the public eye because
she doesn't want to be in the public eye
you know that she has her
family trying to have a twitter account
trying to talk to mainstream media and
say what a wonderful woman she is
um she just wants this over
now is she going to be ever allowed to
live a free life i hope not um
i i i've lost a lot of my belief in our
justice system um even before the
epstein case
however i do hope for the victims that
they will get
some kind of closure they can only get
that if there is
a semblance even a semblance of justice
in in the trial well look it's
absolutely fascinating you've been a
brilliant uh commentator
on it kirby i hope you'll come back in
november
and we'll talk again about the galen
maxwell
trial thank you very much indeed for
joining us just before the next break in
this week
in 1943 the raf
bombed dresden creating a firestorm
killing thousands of people what was the
operation
called a titan b gomorrah
c babylon answer
after the break radio sputnik
[Music]
in the media landscape filled with
so-called journalists acting as
stenographers for their billionaire
bosses
there is a desperate need for news
analysis and perspectives that bug the
status quo
and get to the heart of how domestic and
international events
impact you and me as well as showing how
we can get involved in the struggle
to change that status quo check out by
any means necessary on radio sputnik
monday through friday from 2 to 4 pm
eastern to hear the stories and voices
that mainstream media refuses to tell
you
and join us as we connect the political
social and economic movements shaping
the world around us
that's by any means necessary monday
through friday at 2-4 pm eastern
right here on radio sputnik
hello peach of express smoking
what is it you want oh you want an
ill-advised interview on the bbc
a cheese pizza extra immature and a
rural bailout
no we don't take taxpayers money yeah
but we do take contactless
would you like a scene for that mr
[Music]
princess
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
the raf bombing of dresden was
operation gomorrah
uh now how's the poll doing are you
watching the tokyo olympics yes
22 no 69
see they should be cancelled nine
percent down
one now let me give you the phone
numbers uh if you're
in the uk uh the number is 0808 one
nine six double five double two that's
9 it's entirely
free nowadays so it won't cost you a
single penny
ditto if you're in the united states but
here the number
is plus one eight four four 944
double three double four you can email
the show
of course on air at moats dot tv
and you can tweet me at george galloway
at rt uk news no
freedom how's it been for you let's
catch up
with mot's medic dr ranjit brah
as we come to the end dr ranji of the
first week of
uh freedom how's it all working out
george good to be with you um so freedom
is a
is a relative term we can't be more free
after the pandemic than we have been
before it and of course many social
problems remain but from the point of
view of
uh the coronavirus restrictions were
lifted but simultaneously with that
we've been inundated with warning
messages that despite
there being no legal obligation any
longer
to isolate that really we're under a lot
of serious threat we should continue to
wear masks we should continue to observe
social distancing wherever possible
certainly we it's become
a legal requirement in london transport
to continue to wear masks
though in fact all of those transport
systems are absolutely packed
and masks will have little impact on
transmission but what have we seen in
terms of the numbers
well there was a lot of um concern
amongst academics virologists
and medical doctors to an extent as well
as policy makers that we were
seeing another wave of infections
now when i last spoke to you it was my
strong belief that um
the amount of immunity generated by
principally uh immunization of the
vulnerable sick and elderly and secondly
then
those who haven't been immunized more
than half of them having
already had the chronovirus but that
would insulate us against the worst
effects and i think that's largely
still true um if you compare the
waves of infection we had in the first
wave and the second wave
was quite clear that there were very
major surges in deaths very
major numbers of deaths by a large
amount of excess
mortality yes principally driven by the
elderly yes principally driven by the
infirm
but very real figures nonetheless are
people dying from not with
uh the coronavirus and i think we're
probably looking around
150 000 people really having died
in terms of our excess mortality during
this pandemic george
if you look at this third wave whilst
the numbers probably has peaked actually
so we were looking last
week at around the 50 000 yeah they've
gone down
in uh in the last week they have and it
seems that they're currently
consistently going down for the last
five days uh six days
and we're around the 30 000 mark and
we've not seen
the spike in deaths so anything like the
spike in deaths associated with
the last two waves so so i still say
overall
you know that this has been the correct
time to come out of um very strict
social isolation and lockdown type
measures
um both because it's summer both because
school is coming to a close
but most importantly not just for
behavioral reasons not just for
social reasons but actually because um
the
vaccination program has largely been
successful at isolating the most
vulnerable the most elderly those
from whom the greatest number of deaths
and hospitalizations
came george yes i want to turn to
the the vaccination uh
i was struck by um
piers morgan uh with whom i have quite
friendly
relations there's no shading freud in
this
for me but he wrote today that he almost
died in the last
week or so from coronavirus even though
he's had both injections and
is the one of the greatest champions of
uh vaccination and indeed other lockdown
measures though he doesn't always
practice
what he preaches and he
was in a mass crowd at the euros
at the football championships at wembley
and believes that's where he caught it
um
is there a sense in which
the vaccines which are wholly support
and absolutely encourage everyone to
have
but the vaccines haven't aren't quite
up to the mark as we thought they were
uh not quite providing the kind of
protection that we thought they would
um it's an interesting question george
and you know i think it's always
dangerous to judge um overall population
efficacy by individual and equivalent
paces
um but there are several studies we've
seen around the world which have
shown that it is possible to be
vaccinated
and still to get the coronavirus it's
possible to have had the coronavirus
and still get the coronavirus but uh the
numbers are much lower so if we look
there was a very large study after the
first wave conjuncted at some georgia
university where my wife works and
it's quite close to where i live that
showed probably 95 percent protection
against crotavirus from a previous case
of coronavirus
and those who did get it a second time
had much milder course of symptoms and
we're really seeing
similar figures for the majority of
vaccinations they're slightly different
from case to case
and we cautioned when we first talked
about the vaccination these have been
very
rapidly developed vaccinations some of
them are relatively new technologies we
don't know
fully their safety profile and their
efficacy i i
met a friend of mine my son was playing
tennis against
um his son and he said he knew two
people
in their 30s and early 40s
uh who had had the vaccination and had
developed you know um
essentially had strokes uh from from
venus
thromboembolic events and again that you
know it gives you a distorted picture of
the risk of vaccination actually if you
look at the
population statistics it's very safe
still there are these cases of venous
thromboembolism but they're low
in in their in their frequency and
therefore vaccination remains
much the safest course of events i think
probably for anyone over 30
absolutely certainly and vaccination
still remains very efficacious with a
really greater than 90 percent maybe 95
efficacy against serious outcomes
and much much lower chances of
hospitalization death there have been
very few cases
um you're talking about probably around
100 people who've been double vaccinated
who have end up
in hospital and have passed away but
that's 100 out of the entire population
those are extremely low numbers so
actually
you know clearly to me uh vaccination
essentially has been
very successful our most successful
measure that's not to say that i think
this is the way we should have
handled the pandemic or our record has
been examined indeed uh
like the uh the uh the uh no apocryphal
irishman we wouldn't have started from
here uh
on the road to dublin but on that
subject
is there any comparative study
of the efficacy of say the russian
vaccine the chinese vaccine
and the anglo-american vaccines
i have not seen any um group who have
taken all of the different vaccines and
conducted their own randomized control
trial but what there are is very large
sets of real-world data
i mean the chinese if you want to talk
about the people who've handled a
vaccine really well
through their uh you know incredible
public health measures mobilizing their
economy and resources to
isolate the virus and identify every
positive case they have occasionally um
you know little outbreaks in cities
and they literally must test the entire
city not the whole country but the
entire city
and all of the people who they find have
test positive symptomatic and
asymptomatic because we know
there are very many asymptomatic cases
they then put into social isolation so
they support them
during the process of their recovery and
as a result they still
at this point have had 92 000 cases
they're a country of 1.4
billion uh population and they've
administered
1.5 billion doses of their vaccine so
they are working towards
building up a vaccine-mediated herd
immunity despite their very low number
of cases so they no longer have to be on
this
permanent alert um against new
introduction of virus
um but there have been lots of separate
studies you know lots of separate
studies of real-world efficacy
of all of the vaccines and the vast
majority of them have actually
relatively good efficacy astrazeneca
probably slightly lower but still
against the things that really count you
know against the hospitalizations
against the deaths
pretty much all the vaccines that have
gone to to market been recognized by the
world health organization
and that includes the the sign of farm
and the silent sign of vac
that the two major chinese vaccines have
proved incredibly efficacious and
actually
they've all proved efficacious against
all the different variants
in terms of those most alarming
statistics and and you can see the
difference then
between you know countries who have
large amounts of vaccine as
we currently do um as china does
and between countries like indonesia now
who are experiencing
an enormous um you know a surge in their
coronavirus cases
and again this kind of shortage of
oxygen shortage of hospital places
many people dying at home it's extremely
distressing there's not over in the
world by long shorts and
it's interesting to see i read um an
article just just today in in the bmj
which essentially said if you look at
the actual um excess mortality figures
and while we have recognized in the
world 4.2 million
cases of deaths from coronavirus almost
000 sorry 200 million cases
of chronovirus and 4 million deaths
actually the figures are likely to be
double that
and expected um to become close to nine
and a half million
coronavirus deaths from the pandemic
worldwide
by september so you know we this story
has some way to run uh
it's a story again of health inequality
of us needing to ensure that countries
are vaccinated
and indeed of that the world's normal
political injustice is playing out again
in the field of medicine so you can see
that
america not only is tightening its
regime change efforts in countries like
cuba and venezuela but actually they've
used this
opportunity their stranglehold on the
financial system to stop venezuela
using its own money for example the
money which is sequestrated
by this in by the city uh uh sorry by
the bank of
england here several billion of their
gold billion stopping
venezuela using its own money to buy
uh the vaccines from the from the gavi
from the worldwide initiative which is
meant to guarantee
health equality and protect the health
of populations while they're stopping
countries whose political system they
oppose for example
from having access to technology which
would allow them
to fight the pandemic so deliberately
inflicting death and destruction
hoping that through doing so through
this kind of punishment beating on
populations
of countries that they will destabilize
them enough to affect regime change and
this is the
this is the government uh world
government situation we're living
dominated by i'm afraid the united
biological st couldn't you well it
absolutely is
biological warfare i mean there's lots
of uh immigration into venezuela
um you know which will take
coronavirus with it how much of that is
deliberately mitigated and how much of
that is incidental is hard to say
but it's quite clear if you look at the
case of cuba there have been so many
examples of
viruses dengue fever against the human
population against their swine
population against their poultry
population
deliberately introduced precisely to
create famine conditions and i'm afraid
that the pandemic is being used
and the destabilizing effects of the
pandemic are being used to heighten
these kind of regime change operations
so
there are many different stories to tell
from coronavirus but in terms of
britain in terms of our freedom day in
terms of our relaxion
of restrictions you know i do think it's
time actually to relax restrictions i am
not
worried about wearing a mask in public
in hospitals we are still pretty much
mandated to do so and many
situations we'd be encouraged to do so
but actually i think we're going to see
the petering out of this wave
and while coronavirus will not vanish
from britain i think its effects
will become you know increasingly weak
there's less and less likely to cause
serious uh
injury serious harm serious respiratory
disease and certainly less and less
likely to cause death of course i'm
sorry for
piers morgan and other people who are
suffering from the effects
and i would as you say absolutely
encourage the population
who are vulnerable to seek vaccination i
i know there's a high level of mistrust
and some of the sections of the
population have most reason to mistrust
the government
mistrust them also on this question of
whether the vaccine is safe and whether
it's a good idea
to take it and it's a shame to see their
level of economic marginalization
impact them and further give them even
worse outcomes
uh in the current situation george dr
angie broth thanks for joining us
on the mother of all talk shows as
always
now here are the phone numbers again if
you're calling from the united kingdom
it's completely free 0808 196
double five if you're in the us
equally free it's plus one eight
four four nine four four double three
double four now coming up after the news
we'll be talking about climate change
talking to a very considerable expert
matthew
capucci who is an atmospheric scientist
and meteorologist the
situation outside this studio has now
become
quite grave will be
look at this this england summer has
come
to an abrupt end southern
england is submerged
extremely heavy rain uh this is a video
from
hampstead in london eventually road
believe that
or not and this is just in the last
couple of
hours this is from the sun newspaper
there's been also severe flooding in
shepherd's bush
in hammersmith in kensington which is
very close to here and there's
widespread
flat flash flooding expected
tonight my goodness we chose the right
time
yeah he's up to his knees in that water
and look at the cars
you can no longer drive rains park in
london
my goodness this is all
in the last four hours we chose the
right
day to talk about climate change with
matthew
capucci but first it's the news with
jamie lowe
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news
large event with thousands of spectators
such as football matches could be open
only to fully vaccinated people from
october
under uk government plans talks are
underway with england's premier league
to discuss whether supporters who have
not received both jabs
could be barred from entry according to
the pa news agency
the rule could be also used for lower
divisions and
other sports and for other seated events
with a capacity
more than twenty thousand people for
unseated events such as gigs the
threshold could be as low as
5 000 attendees a government source said
it's important that fans can continue to
watch sporting events over the autumn
which is why we're exploring the role
vaccines might play in this this will
not only allow full capacity stadiums
but
has the added bonus of incentivizing
people of all ages
to go and get their jab crime and
policing minister kip malthouse did not
deny that the government was considering
vaccine passports for large events a uk
government minister has apologized to
those who've experienced delays at the
uk's airports over the weekend
people have complained of total chaos at
airports as summer holidays began for
millions
two hour long queues to show kovid 19
documentation before boarding being
allowed airside were reported at
heathrow on saturday
while there were complaints of a lack of
staff at stansted airport causing
chaotic scenes
airports and airlines were expecting
their busiest weekend of the year
with hundreds more flights and thousands
more passengers than at any time during
the covert 19 pandemic
crime and policing minister kit
malthouse apologised for the delays
and suggested that airline staff could
be among those made exempt from having
to isolate if identified as a closed
contact
of someone who test positive for
coronavirus
australian politicians have condemned
protests against coronavirus
restrictions amid a rising cases
thousands marched through sydney
yesterday to demand an
end to lockdown measures with smaller
demonstrations taking place in melbourne
and brisbane
at least 57 people involved in the
sydney protest have been charged while
more than 500
have been fined the state recorded 141
new infections on sunday
the second highest daily increase of the
year there are fears of a further rising
cases following saturday's protests
some 30 million australians are being in
lockdown
after state governments reimpose
restrictions in recent weeks
to combat the highly contagious delta
variant which has driven up cases across
the country
fewer than 14 of the population have
been fully vaccinated
a far lower percentage than most
european countries and the us
a man woman and child have died and a
seven-year-old boy has been left
fighting for his life after getting into
difficulty in the water on loch lomond
in scotland
police scotland was called to reports of
concerns for people's safety in the
water near pulpit rock on saturday
evening
at about 6 40 p.m a 41 year old man a 29
year old woman and a nine-year-old boy
were pronounced dead at the scene while
another boy
seven was taken to intensive care at the
royal hospital for children in glasgow
where he remained
five people have died in the past 24
hours in scotland
after getting into trouble in water
belgium has been hit by floods in the
second time in just
over a week the provinces of namu and
walum brabant
southeast of the capital city of
brussels were among the worst hit after
thunderstorms and heavy rain reached the
country
on saturday in dynant in the welling
region heavy rainfall washed away cars
leaving them strewn across the town
deputy mayor robert klossett said no
deaths or
injuries had been reported but the
floods were worse
than last week's kidnappers in nigeria
have seized a man who was sent to
deliver a ransom payment to secure the
release of dozens of abducted school
children the elderly man was sent by
children's parents after they managed to
raise 30 million
naira that's around 53 000 pounds by
selling land and other possessions
the north of the country is in the midst
of a wave of school abductions carried
out by criminals for profit
ransoms are frequently paid but this is
a rare case where the person carrying
the cash
has also been taken the kidnappers
called up the school's headteacher to
say that the money delivered was not the
agreed
sum the 136 students were taken from an
islamic school
in tajin niger state in late may the u.s
government has requested to keep ansa
kulas's job a secret in the harry dunn
damages case due to
national security concerns the 19 year
old's parent charlotte charles and tim
dunn traveled to the u.s last month to
pursue a civil case
against his alleged killer seculas as
well as her husband
jonathan harry died in august 2019 after
being struck off his motorbike by
seculars
who was driving her car on the wrong
side of the road near
raf crouton in northamptonshire both she
and her husband are believed to work for
the u.s
intelligence services
and finally norwegians have been left
awestruck by what experts say was an
unusually large meteor that illuminated
the night sky
in the country's south east footed shows
powerful flashes of light over norway
followed by what witnesses described as
loud bangs earlier today
norwegian police say they received a
flurry of emergency calls but there were
no reports of injuries or damage
a team of experts are hunting the meteor
which they believe landed in a forest
near the capital oslo
the norwegian meteor network says
today's fireball was visible for at
least five seconds
after it appeared at about 1am local
time traveling at about 36
500 miles per hour the meteor could be
seen over large parts of the southern
scandinavia region the network says
norwegian astronomer vegard wrecker said
his wife was awake at the time and she
could hear shaking
in the air before an explosion she
assumed something heavy
was falling near the house initial
research suggests the meteor may have
hit ground in a woodland area called
fine marker about 60 kilometers
west of oslo and that's the latest here
on sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george callaway only on sputnik
radio
showing his normal perspicacity
the editor of this show decided to
cover the issue of climate change and we
booked one of the world's experts on it
matthew capucci and then the heavens
opened
and london has fallen
to the wave after wave after wave
of rain water absolutely extraordinary
scenes that you saw i think
on the news and just before the news
that i'm not sure how i'm gonna get out
of this studio
tonight if that was outside here
i think i'd be bedding down here in the
studio
for the night i certainly don't fancy
swimming
back to my hotel so
we chose a good day to talk to matthew
capucci who's an
atmospheric scientist and meteorologist
it's going to be i think a busy
profession
in the next year or two he's been kind
enough
to join us now matthew uh thank you
for that uh perfect timing
uh tell us what's going on
in the weather by the way i left
scotland
uh at midday and it was baking hot
hence my straw hat and now i find myself
in the deluge
why such extreme weather in london
and the south of the country right now
i don't have any i don't have uh audio
we'll have to come back we'll have to
come back to
matthew maggie anderson says love the
olympics
watch the skateboarding last night are
you pulling my leg here maggie
brilliant is it an olympic sport maybe
not but it's very different makes for
great tv maggie if the day ever comes
when i'm reduced to watching
skateboarding
it's time to put me away red chilean
says shout out to
giulio la cruz campaign for his second
olympic medal
this time in heavyweight cuban boxers
are the pride of latin america aren't
they just
and neil curry says pity biden wasn't in
the russian
boat parade today right at the back on a
jet ski
in a star-spangled knuckle bag waving
and looking confused if he had been near
he wouldn't have known anyway uh
kaltrabant
says japan wants to sweep the fukushima
tragedy under the carpet fukushima
is a worst tragedy than c o
v covert i think he means dany says when
i heard russian athletes
had to compete under rock i thought they
meant the russian orthodox church
and david otness says russia was set up
with fake drug charges following the
sochi games i can well believe it
and david raynor says we need an
olympics
for overweight middle-aged men
and sabbah crosby says george survived
maxwell's silver hammer very drool
sabha and baron says he's wearing a
different hat
what's happened to his old hat
is it all right of course it's all right
it's summer
or it was where i was a few hours ago
and johnny don levy says the man from
del monte says
yes looking good george uh apropos
nothing rangers just beat real madrid
2-1 my goodness what an achievement
or is it a case of how far the mighty
have fallen anyway well done rangers no
one can take that result
away a big jim tang says what do you
expect
keep cutting trees down in brazil the
rain
has to fall somewhere and from last
week's show
george i thought your last caller last
week cynthia from westminster
who sounded like a very middle-class
well-educated
political activist had very negative and
demeaning views
about white people in general including
yourself
it bordered on racism in my view says
roger
in london no it it didn't bother on
racism and cynthia is definitely
not a racist i was a bit offended
at her tone but she raised
important points and a lot of people are
interested in whether or not she calls
again tonight
like ian in hanslow who says this
cynthia confusing class war with racism
is cynthia disliked on a personal basis
rather than racial
cynthia's ethnicity may be incidental
i'm just speaking as a widower who was
married
to a sino-indian mauritian lady for 21
years
thanks for that ian and tony says
in that outfit i expected you to be
inspecting tropical fruits the man
from moats says yes
very good let's give here here's a video
look
we've been monitoring all this flash
flooding in london tonight here's
another
extraordinary video we found on twitter
taken by thori bjork around 5 pm
it's a water spout a storm drain
seemingly exploding under the pressure
of the water it's another thing wrong
with hammersmith bridge will we ever be
able to use
that bridge it is actually
extraordinary anyway we've linked up
with matthew
uh matthew capucci is a world
renowned atmospheric scientist and
meteorologist
he's given us his time entirely for free
matthew
i don't know if you knew it was entirely
for free but it is
thank you very much for joining us uh
what's going on
in britain right now
yeah so at the moment you have a bit of
a low pressure system off to your
northeast but as is oftentimes the case
when you get these lows they're kind of
these big swirls in the atmosphere
almost like atmospheric cinnamon buns so
to speak
and so you can have alternating tendrils
of warm moist air
and cooler drier air they're being
swirled together and that's why the
weather today has been so erratic in
places
you got kind of a big feeder band of
moisture riding northwards contributing
to these heavy downpours the cold air
that's falling on the backside
helping to kick that really unstable air
upwards and generate prolific downpours
and because this low isn't moving all
that fast
the rain can kind of back build and
stall and you get round after round of
it so
unfortunately this rainfall looks to
stay around for much of the evening
hours into the overnight and it doesn't
look like there's too much relief in
sight
for at least a little while tomorrow
should be better for the time being it's
a pretty unsettled day
it's uh part of a series though isn't it
of extraordinary weather events
in europe and in asia
we saw extraordinary flooding in china
we've seen things that we never thought
we'd see
in a highly developed country like
germany
where streets are being uh
basically flushed away cars and people
being flushed down the road is that the
same explanation
for them so i think what we saw recently
in central europe was more attributed to
a combination of ordinary weather and
then kind of a turbo boost by climate
change so what we saw was a cut off low
this low pressure system that was kind
of pinched off from the jet stream and
so as a result there's nothing to carry
it from west to east
it just kind of sat and languished and
unloaded moisture
now one of the things that we see with
climate change is that it has potential
to take ordinary weather events
and push them to more significant levels
and so
the warmer the world is the warmer the
atmosphere is the more moisture it can
hold and that contributes to these heavy
downpours
and so you take a system that would have
had heavy rainfall to begin with
and add in a bit of extra moisture and
cause it to stall for a while
and suddenly this ordinarily you know
decent event becomes something
really significant with an even higher
impact and so i think that's what we saw
the past couple weeks we saw that in
europe we saw that in asia as well
zhengzhou suffered serious flooding with
more than about uh a meter of rain
falling
in just one day's time they had 200
millimeters in just an hour and so they
saw extreme flooding as well
i think that what we're seeing now is
kind of the fingerprint of climate
change being tapped onto ordinary events
pushing things into the extraordinary
yeah i mean
in your scientific field
is it fair to say that there is now
zero doubt that we are experiencing
significant climate change we could
argue about what caused it we could
argue about what we need to do about it
and many people would the dichotomy of
green versus
growth and so on but that there is
extraordinary climate change going on
is no longer capable of rebuttal am i
right
you're exactly right there we have so
many attribution studies that look at
particular weather events that say
this simply would have would not have
happened without climate change most
recently in the united states we had
in the northwestern part of the u.s and
southwestern canada so british columbia
where temperatures hit 50 degrees
celsius which is
absolutely unheard of for canada one
town light and british columbia
had three days where back to back to
back they broke the canadian national
record temperature
and you know what happened in the fourth
day the entire town burned down from
extreme wildfires
that were catalyzed by the warm dry
conditions and so
we're seeing events like this that were
made 150 times more
likely thanks to climate change we're
seeing other things that simply wouldn't
happen without climate change and so
yes we're used to ordinary weather and
climate but when you have
kind of this preferential push by
climate change suddenly things that in
the past would have been ordinary are
being boosted and made much more extreme
and the unfortunate reality is we're
kind of past that point where
where you know we can kind of reverse at
this point it's not a matter of whether
or not we change our ways it's a matter
of
whether or not we can slow down the rate
at which
the atmosphere is changing slow down the
rate at which the system is changing
and to that end i i think it's it's
important that people remember
we're not trying to avoid climate change
at this point like it's happening it's
ongoing right now
we're trying to change faster than our
environment we're trying to evolve more
quickly than the conditions can
and in many areas given the
infrastructure that's an extreme
challenge
yeah an extreme challenge everywhere uh
in the world there have been of course
extreme climate changes before
we've had an ice age we've had
times when you grew grapes and made wine
along hadrian's wall uh in in the north
of england the south of scotland
um so we have had and survived
climate changes before to what extent
are you
worried about how dramatic
this climate change period is going to
be
i think that's a really good question
and it's one that we'd have to answer on
a very local level because there will be
winners of climate change and there will
be disproportionately more losers
the issue is that our infrastructure is
built to withstand
100-year events for the most part we
know that if there's going to be a flood
for example
we should plan for kind of the worst
case near we get in 100 years now
unfortunately
one of the challenges now what once in
the past would have been a 100 year
event
might now be a 10 a 20-year event so the
recurrence intervals with which these
events are occurring
is is becoming much narrower we're
seeing these sorts of extreme events
more
and over a wider area at the same time
too
we're having kind of climate regions
shift so in the united states for
example
boston a city in the northern part will
in about 40 50 years perhaps see the
weather that washington d.c will
and that's a completely different type
of environment and so the infrastructure
that we've really set up for
and based our planning around in terms
of the conditions
is going to have to be adjusted to
accommodate that and so i think
going forward i'm
not necessarily worried about the
survival of the species i mean you see a
lot of headlines like that that's mostly
clickbait
what i am worried about is our
infrastructure and if we've planned
adequately for what we need to
based on what's coming we've built fine
for what's happened in the past but
we're to the point now where conditions
are changing quickly enough that the
past is not an accurate indicator
of the future and so we can't we can't
really prepare based on what we've seen
before
we have to prepare on what's coming up
next so you're not and i'm
not a catastrophist uh
who believes that we're hurtling towards
the demise
of the species of the planet uh
but what do you think is the overarching
reason
for the heating up i mean i talked
earlier about the
the heat map in the 1970s which
had some very hot summers but compared
to the heat map
of the last couple of years one map is
vividly red and the other not
except for a few places that you would
kind of imagine would be extremely
red um is that where we're
headed are we headed for a hotter world
i think so and we have to remember that
in the past you're exactly right we have
had climate changes before
they were more natural in nature you go
back you know hundreds of thousands to
millions of years
we had what was called kind of a hot
house earth and so we had temperatures
that were mild we had tropical plants
all the way up to about 80 degrees
north there were rainforests in many
more areas but conversely we've also had
ice ages so the climate
does change in various cycles we call
these milankovitch cycles they're based
on
the periodicity of earth's orbit they're
based on the shape of earth's orbit
they're based on earth's axial tilt
and a bunch of things that sometimes
combine or overlap in certain ways that
allow us to get more sunshine or less
sunshine
and so that's something that's been
happening pretty much since the dawn of
time and it will continue
the thing there though the changes that
they see
occur in the order of thousands to tens
of thousands of years
what we're doing is accelerating our
climate on the time scale of tens to
maybe hundreds of years
and so the rapidity with which it's
occurring is something that has been for
the most part unprecedented before
and so i think that's really what's
remarkable about this
and in the past we've never had
infrastructure you know
the human kind hasn't really been a lot
been around
long enough in terms of our current
societal infrastructure
to experience any of these changes
before which i i think is important to
remember
in terms of just how red will get we're
we're undergoing something called
positive feedback mechanisms in other
words earth
is sitting in kind of an unstable state
or earth's
thermostat has always been very delicate
in that if you nudge it one way or
another
it will kind of take off and have a
snowball effect and so if you start
heating the earth through greenhouse
gases for example you start awakening
other mechanisms for example
the polar ice caps they start melting
but the polar ice caps are white they're
shiny they reflect a lot of light into
outer space and so if you have those ice
caps melt
suddenly you're not reflecting so much
sunlight away and the earth is taking in
more sunlight and heating up
even more or you're cooking up more
water vapor into the atmosphere that
trap seed even more effectively
or you're melting arctic permafrost
which is releasing greenhouse gases
and those accelerate the climate change
even more or you're sparking more
wildfires
they release greenhouse gases and you
get these positive feedback mechanisms
and so i think to that end our climate
models may not be overly
accurate in terms of the pace of climate
change we know it's ongoing we know it's
occurring
but there's a good chance based on
recent events and based on these
feedback mechanisms
that we may be accelerating even more
quickly than we had thought in the past
and i think that's the key takeaway of
this yes there have been climate changes
before
they were natural they heard on the
order of tens of thousands of years
sometimes
what we're doing is unnatural it's
anthropogenic it's man-made and on the
order of tens to
perhaps hundreds of years and
beyond uh laying in some umbrellas for
this week in london
what can we realistically do about that
matthew
i think the biggest thing is twofold we
can plan for
what's ahead in terms of changing our
infrastructure so
drainage issues relocating a little
farther inland from the coast
making sure that people have the
infrastructure for air conditioning for
example
europe is extremely susceptible to heat
events and in central and eastern europe
not many people have air conditioning at
all
and so you can easily have tens of
thousands of people die from a single
heat wave it's happened before
many times it just doesn't really get
the media attention because the deaths
unfortunately are what we call
scavenging
or harvesting and that the people who
may have had underlying conditions they
might be the elderly vulnerable
populations
who may have been more susceptible
anyway suddenly you're kind of nudging
them and
kind of pushing them over the edge and
they unfortunately pass away from it
but it doesn't really capture the media
attention it should so that's an
enormous issue
but we should start planning for things
like that we need to have more air
conditioners out there we need to make
sure people
know what to do we like i said better
drainage we need to make sure we're
aware of the potential for flood events
agriculture we need to start planting
crops that are
i guess more resilient for the
conditions that we can expect in the
future
and at the same time we really just need
to make sure people are educated on the
effects of the local level because what
happens in
the united states for example will be
different from what we see in the uk
will be different from what we see in
asia
it's really how climate change is
affecting folks on a local level
now that's one aspect of it we need to
really adapt and mitigate
for the most part and try to plan
accordingly
the other thing we can do is of course
taking steps to limit future warming
that said that's something a lot of
people don't really feel the urgency to
do because it's not going to correct the
problem overnight and it very well may
not even in our lifetimes
this is something we're talking about
four five six generations in the future
that will see the effects of what we're
doing now and so even if we stopped
all emission of greenhouse gases today
we could expect the earth to continue
warming for perhaps 50
100 more years thanks to ocean
outgassing
thanks to everything we put up in the
atmosphere now thanks to the long
half-lifes of these molecules
which it is unfortunate but
it really requires kind of playing the
long game and paying it forward
we can make differences but it's going
to affect the next generation for us
it's almost too little too late really
well explained matthew i've got a call a
good one i'm told
uh if you wouldn't mind staying on mike
in
south carolina mike welcome what would
you like to do
george what would you like to ask
matthew
hey jordan matthew it's great to talk to
you i i didn't want to address this idea
of climate change and how i think it
actually is
an existential threat uh to human
existence i mean
we talk about the change in climate and
how it's been changing but you know
uh humans have never been on this planet
uh as we know them you know homo sapiens
since it's been this hot never have has
it been this hot since humans have been
on the planet
and not only that but the the future
holds
way more increases in temperature for us
than uh than what we're seeing right now
i mean we're going to blow by this two
degree
centigrade mark like it's like it's
standing still and and we're probably on
our way to more like four or five
centigrade and there's a number of
people out there
that you can get in touch with watch on
on the uh you know
on the internet people like guy
mcpherson who's
i understand that some people think he's
a doomsday person but you
also listen to people like paul beckwith
who is studying the
the uh climate on the uh in the arctic
and it's it's it's stunning how fast
we are moving towards an ice-free arctic
and if that happens
uh you know this planet is is really in
serious trouble
because that is the refrigerator for the
planet
uh matthew uh some advice for you there
to
do some studying on the internet uh you
are of course an extremely learned man
uh what would your response be uh to
mike in south carolina
well mike thanks again so much for
tuning in i think you raised some really
good points
and and i think that you hit the nail in
the head when you talked about these
thresholds out there
i will say that in terms of the actual
thresholds we've heard the number two
degrees celsius floating around
many times we see it in the media a lot
and
i almost think that number does us a bit
of a disservice in that
we so often see this number floated
around but there's no magic threshold
it's not a
yes or no binary switch on off it's
something that the more
we delay our our actions and our
response the more quickly climate change
will accelerate and that's what we're
seeing right now now
in terms of the actual temperatures i
part of my job as a meteorologist is
communicating weather events and weather
events
in the context of climate change to
people and i always tell folks you know
most people don't give a darn about a
two degree increase if i were to put you
in a
neighboring room of your house with the
temperature a degree or two warmer
there's a strong chance you wouldn't
notice that and so
i think the focus is oftentimes too much
on the actual temperature and not on
these collateral effects
the fact that a two degree increase in
temperature might correspond to 12 to 15
percent
more water in the air and more
significant rainfall events
the fact that the two degrees celsius
increase may cause a change in where we
see tornado activity or more
may cause more rapid intensification of
tropical cyclones
now i don't see this as an existential
threat i'll be very clear there will be
populations that
are displaced there will be people who
have to make mass exodus
to to relocate to different areas there
may be some areas that
in terms of how they're currently
inhabited may no longer be feasible to
be that way i mean phoenix arizona
we're talking about a city that will
routinely be over 120 degrees
fahrenheit by you know 20
40 20 50 and california the wildfires
they're seeing out there
are devastating and that's something we
can expect to see more of in the future
and so there are areas that
the infrastructure will have to change
so it could be an existential threat if
action wasn't to be you know taken i i
do think that there are steps people can
take
to make sure they're in a better
position both geographically and in
terms of vulnerability than they are
currently
and i think that really depends on what
their hazards are whether they're
susceptible to the
climate catalyzed hurricanes the
wildfires the
change in tornado frequency over the
lower 48 the
the change in heat patterns across
europe so ultimately it's down to a
local level
the warming itself the the arctic i mean
i'm not in the arctic right now most
people don't go up to the arctic
they really don't give a darn about that
but that's what we see in the media so
often so i think we need to shift the
conversation from
these you know the polar bears are are
having to swim
to more of how is climate change
affecting my geographic region in terms
of the specific hazards that i deal with
and how can i adapt accordingly
and do we have in place matthew
governments in your country and mine
that are
fully enough seized of this
in my opinion i would say not in the way
they should be
we still in the united states for
example we have a flood insurance
program that ensures homes that are
built right on the water
now i i got some backlash with this
comment before i don't think it's overly
controversial if your house is on stilts
then you're too close to the water and
yet we have people who build right on
the beach in the united states we have
people who build in flood zones
and and people are are willing to kind
of take that loss
if they have high insurance premiums and
that's
that's just one example of an issue that
we faced
or houston the entire city of houston
for example floods
incessantly infrastructure cannot handle
the amount of rainfall they're seeing
now and i i
loathe to think about what it will be
like in 30 40 50 years as gulf of mexico
rainfall continues to
to you know become more prolific or
near the coast we're seeing a dramatic
uptick in the propensity for hurricanes
to rapidly intensify before becoming
before moving ashore
and i don't think people near the
coastline especially in the southern
united states
are building homes the way that they
should to be more resilient to these
storms and so ultimately
i think historically in the united
states anyway and i can't speak for the
uk but i know in the united states
the attitude has always been well
somebody's going to be struck by a
natural disaster it's cheaper to rebuild
than cheaper to to build resiliently
in the future with these natural
disasters becoming more common and and
with a wider footprint that may no
longer be the case and so we may have to
have a shift in strategy as to how we
plan our communities
fascinating thank you mike and carolina
and thank you
matthew capucci for brilliantly
explaining
the phenomenon that we are now living
through
um the latest forecast here is
i'm going to get very wet indeed after
the show uh now next question uh
we did dresden in 1973
led zeppelin had what stolen from them
at the hilton hotel in new york
a 200 000 in cash
b their passports see their tour bus
answer after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
now don't forget you can download the
podcast of this program
a finely edited highlights version of
this three-hour epic
it's being listened to now all around
the world huge numbers
are downloading the as it were compact
version of the show of course in the uk
and the us but listen to these countries
that downloaded it last week japan
india denmark saudi arabia
korea switzerland uae
and hong kong in china all of those had
significant
audiences of last week's show search
moats m-o-a-t-s on the app
where you get your podcast from
[Music]
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have as long as you have
questions
we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
are you watching the tokyo olympics i'll
tell you
how many are in just a minute but the
answer
to my question was this led zeppelin
it is alleged in 1973
had two hundred thousand dollars in cash
stolen from them
at the hilton hotel in new york call me
suspicious
and anxious because i'm staying at a
hotel this very evening
but it won't happen to me because i've
not got more than 40 pounds
in cash but here's the uh answer
to the uh poll are you watching the
tokyo olympics
yes 22 percent i'm surprised at that
no 69 or
c they should be cancelled nine percent
now
the mother of all talk shows podcast is
being listened to all around the world
huge numbers
are downloading this week's highlights
in the uk
and in the us but also in countries like
japan
india denmark saudi arabia you probably
get
executed for that korea switzerland the
uae
and hong kong in china and the podcast
listenership
last week increased by 30
in a single week so please go to your
normal app where you get your podcasts
and make sure you listen to ours
let's take some calls uh scott is in
london
on the maxwell issue go ahead scott
hi george can you hear me yes i can
thank you
we met briefly once in a restaurant in
westminster
uh oh god about
every 2000 something like that wow just
a handshake
excellent um glad to meet you again
back in the day when you were gorgeous
um so
george um uh so
i made a comment a couple weeks ago
about uh you know
i was in the french foreign legion and i
didn't get my passport removed from my
anything like that
oh i remember yes yes yeah we're
speaking about
uh maxwell yes uh after the legion
i became a yacht captain and i
met many people like maxwell
in khashoggi uh uh what's his name uh
rashida mukbang uh many many people like
that
most of them were incredibly charming
maxwell was less charming but he was
really interesting
uh and he was a bit disgusting he had a
reputation
for like uh he used to wipe his arse
with a towel and it just dropped the
towel on the stew this had to pick it up
and things like this but what amazes me
about maxwell
is that he was second world war hero
and he was known for charging machine
gun positions
on his own he was actually decorated by
montgomery he got the military cross
yeah
he got the military cross uh after the
second world war
he then i mean because he spokesman's
language i think he came from
czechoslovakia and he spoke like seven
or eight languages
and he became part of the british spy
service
and he was in berlin and
he his job was to collect
you know scientists as the americans the
russians
and the british were doing uh you know
collecting scientists creating
scientific material
somehow or other maxwell managed to
get a train load to our documents back
to the uk
and that was the foundation of per
pergamon press
and he was shunned by the upper classes
and he made his own way he was a bit of
a you know
a bit of a street fighter and yeah
in some ways i have a sort of a bit of
an admiration for the guy
but i mean how he finished up
was disgusting but an interesting fact
which never really seems to come out i i
knew some of the crew on on where they
go in
and an interesting fact on november 5th
he was in the canary islands november
5th 1991 he was in the canary islands
and the boat was going from one island
to another and
he actually gave to the skipper
a latitude and long to longitude
waypoint as to he said he wanted to go
out there like basically doing a
triangle
instead of going in a straight line
doing a triangle
and you know and his excuse was
that he didn't want to be disturbed by
the noise of coming back in the port
and at that latitude and longitude is
where he disappeared
yeah and your theory is what
well uh i think he
had arranged to meet somebody there
and yeah i mean who knows it's
interesting you know in the canary
islands
uh you know there it's impossible to
find
one on the spanish law the local
magistrate
has complete control over somebody over
all investigations so there is only one
person that you have to noble
um and he was
i think it was accused he went overboard
he had to be buried in the
on the friday
you cannot use him a body for the amount
of olives
and the whole thing seems just seems to
be incredibly
suspicious right now i'm not an actress
from what from what i've heard maxwell
was a spy for the british government for
the american government for the israeli
government and
for the russian government yeah i was
going to make that point
uh by the way this is a a fascinating
phone call scott i'm very glad that you
made it uh it makes me think that
there's
still a lot to learn
uh most people will be entirely
oblivious
to the things that you're describing and
i know and i'm about to describe
uh and yet here we are in 2021
his daughter is widely accused though
not in court
yet of herself being an intelligence
agent uh for the united states it's
important to
uh emphasize that not just israel but
the united states and israel uh
i agree with you uh that in the
beginning i think it's not contested
uh that robert maxwell was a british
intelligence
uh agent asset and maybe
it's a case of you know once a catholic
or was a catholic
once a british intelligence agent always
a british intelligence agent but he also
worked
as you rightly said for both the united
states
and the soviet union he was a
very frequent visitor to the soviet
union
and to eastern europe he built up
his publishing empire as you rightly say
on scientific journals
which were of course of great interest
in statecraft and of great interest
in the field of espionage
the points you make about the course he
took
on that fateful day
are very interesting i'll give him my
own theory i can't prove it
i believe that he did not commit suicide
i don't believe that he was the kind of
man and i knew him well
uh that would have committed suicide
i think that he either fell
accidentally uh taking uh
micturating over the back of the boat
in the darkness or he was pushed he was
murdered
now you people then say well who would
murder him
if he was an asset for these
intelligence
agents agencies why would they be a part
of killing them well
the answer to that would be in my theory
that there comes a point where your
usefulness
is outweighed by the perils of
your exposure and maxwell was in
such financial trouble way beyond the
ability of anyone to help him
wasn't a case of well i'll i'll give you
a few thousand pounds
to stop you collapsing uh and therefore
being exposed
maxwell was in the hundreds of millions
of pounds of exposure about
to happen at which point he might have
sung like a canary about all the things
he'd done
for all the people he'd done it and
therefore pushing him over the back
of a boat and then giving him a
marvelous send-off
on the mount of olives no less becomes
the more
attractive option last word to you scott
i agree with you 99 on that i don't
think there was yeah i don't think he
was pushed because
you know there was nobody in the crew
that would approach him
but somebody could have come on board i
think he was pulled
yeah i think he had arranged there as a
you know
a waypoint to meet for his escape
and yeah another possibility which was
suggested by
no no no less than prince charles is
that actually the body might be a
difficulty
yeah might have been some somebody else
perhaps he's living on with jeffrey
epstein
in the negev uh
i doubt that very much uh i was i would
think he'd be dead by now and i think
he's actually
you know that he he came to his ultimate
end
that night um but it's been very
interesting speaking with you george
um you're fascinated you got my number
um and by the way uh long before i
actually
knew maxwell and aiden khashoggi and all
that what
um i met sariah khashoggi um and she was
a very interesting character
very glamorous wife of adnan yeah
well yeah and i have picking up young
boys
um and uh yeah you knew her well did you
scott
i gave her body swell um
i thought you were gonna say something
else there we better end it there
although she's she's passed also so
she's beyond uh
beyond suing uh thank you uh scott for a
fascinating
uh discourse uh on everything from
soraya
khashoggi who was english and working
class
but luxuriated in that name
soraya khashoggi and of course
was married to one of the world's
richest men let's go to paul
in liverpool on the issue of covet
passports
go ahead paul good evening george good
evening to everyone listening on the
show
yeah it's just going back to your
conversation um before
your add a few address
for me yeah go ahead yeah yeah you
mentioned about piers morgan and also
a very close friend of yours jokingly
owen jones
both got covered and
got covered also unfortunately so yeah
and never mind i'm sure you'll get over
it
but i mean both of them have had the
vaccines and we've got both vaccines
now my thought is how
i know a ranjeet was saying it's still
efficacious to vaccine but
if they've had both vaccines well uh
yeah i mean it's never been claimed that
if you get both vaccines you can't catch
coronavirus
just that it's quite unlikely that you
will and even more unlikely that you'll
be hospitalized and still more unlikely
that you'll die from it
yeah i mean i suppose in theory everyone
who's vulnerable
and i'm obviously people who aren't
women who've
been vaccinated so i mean really
we should have had immunity by now
really shouldn't we i think that was
ranjeet's point that we're
we're we're pretty close to it herd
immunity doesn't mean you don't get it
it means that you don't get extremely
sick from getting it
yeah i mean also i mean i've got all the
concerns over actually wearing masks
and i mean long-term wear and the masks
and you know
infections by by wearing them all the
time really
that's another concern of mine aim and
the average person just pulls a mask out
of the pocket and puts it on which isn't
isn't exactly clinical or clean is it
you know so
i mean that that's one concern of mine
as well i mean also i mean
i always think that can vaccines be
potentially dangerous
if people can still catch it i mean i
know for one thing miguel friends who
works in the hospital
she's an auxiliary nurse she's filippi
you know she's had the two vaccines both
fires are vaccines and the first one
she's really ill with it she was in bed
uh
bedridden for like five days and then
the next time she had the next one and
she was really
ill with it at one point she even had to
call an ambulance
and basically as far as i'm concerned
that was down
to take him to taking the aim yeah
i i had uh i had two
uh pfizer vaccinations and i had
zero reactions zero side effects
in fact the second one i didn't even
feel it going in that's how good the
nurse was
uh so i mean as ranjit put
anecdotal information is one thing but
the full statistical picture makes clear
that the reason we've broken the
massive number of excess deaths
is because of vaccination not really
because of mass
but because of vaccination paul thanks
for the call
dan is in yorkshire on the same subject
go ahead dan
hi george hi mate
um i um i just wanted to tell you my
personal
story so far is i've just um i tested
positive for covid
um last friday um
friday the 16th so uh what that so now
nine days ago nine days ago how are you
feeling
i'm feeling a lot better now but i've
been i've been very rough to be honest
with you
uh unvaccinated i'm 51 now
51 years old why are you unvaccinated by
choice
yes by choice and um is that a choice
you regret now
no not at all now the fact that i've
actually
i feel like 10 men now obviously i've
got um without what i would consider the
best
the best immunity which is natural
um so i've got a natural immunity now
and so i'm quite happy now
um because uh you know
not many of us uh have been through it
most people have not been through it
what was it like what was the last week
of your life like
it was it was it was i can't i can't
sugarcoat it was tough
i was i was i was at no point ready to
lift the phone in ring 999
um but i spent a lot of time in bed
um do you have difficulty breathing
yes i did um luckily i've
got a bit of home prep anyway so i've
got me over to monitor my blood
on it to oxygen level so i've been i was
watching that quite closely
um um but my wife also had it at the
same time
um we're in the house with four kids
they
they were fine throughout it all
um apart from having to fetch and carry
for us a little bit
of course um but um we were um
we believe that well sarah my wife she
contracted it at the um
the year the football finals at the pub
okay she started first she's vaccinated
um she got it and then passed it on to
me but the kids have been
absolutely fine and they range from
seven to sixteen four of them
very interesting so um yeah i just i
i was i was wondering whether i could
get your opinion on how much you think
this is a public health issue
and how much do you think it's more of a
not a control issue in terms of a a full
foil hat scenario but you know once once
that power is in government
do you think they uh i don't know i find
it difficult to relinquish
no i mean relinquish what
their power to make me wear a mask
come on uh their power to know where i
am they already know where i am
they know where you are if you've got a
mobile phone
uh uh just this uh
working don't have any labor don't don't
go out to labor and
you know this new medical passport thing
going on
i tend to feel as if there's almost a
little bit
more that meets the eye here but
let me throw the question back at you
i don't know you you may be a very
important figure in a very important
field
i don't i wouldn't know uh why would
they want to control you dan
me personally yeah or the massive i'm
talking about
you know the most of the most not you of
course present company accepted
you're you're a very level-headed guy is
clear
but when i see here
read some of the screechers on this
theme i get to wondering why they
imagine
that bill gates or capitalism or the
government would want to control them
i i just don't get it
well they already control us they
control
our lives by owning the economy
um by being in a position to decide
whether we can work or don't work uh
whether we're gonna have enough to live
on or not
capitalism already controls us it
puzzles me why you know
bob in in rotherham imagines
uh that the state or capitalism
has a particular wish to control him
individually beyond what they control
them on
already i i agree with you george
and i must say just before i carry on
my respect for you as an orator is
amazing and you must forgive me at the
moment because i'm quite hard of
thinking at the moment because i'm not
quite myself
it's amazing it's amazing that you're
that you're on the phone as cogent as
you are
after what you've been through i i think
the
the idea of this capitalism thing that
we we have limited
respect for which it's linked with
freedom compared to like
a strict socialist um people going on to
welfare and and not being able to work
and i feel like that
almost the world this great reset and
build back better and all these key
words of team come out with
team um country leaders all over the
world it seems to me to be a little bit
worrying
you shouldn't be any more worried than
you were before
but you shouldn't be any less worried
than you were before
either we're in exactly the same
situation
the rich control everything the rich
countries control everything that was
true before the virus
it's true after it even though we're not
yet
after it i need a pressure i need to
press on done but i'd love to speak to
you another time
because i need to hear from brian in
fife
go ahead brian good evening george how
are you this evening by the grace of god
i'm good thank you
a fellow scott and also i appreciate him
the great city that you're from as a
city of dundee oh excellent many a great
scientist from that city
will mention william playfair well very
good
not many people would mention him go
ahead
what i wanted to discuss today was um
basically the
dominant coming interview
so give me the highlights well i'm going
to i'm going to quote
what what was said we've got the
transcript here and i just want you to
see but your thoughts
are enough okay this is quite
interesting so yeah he's dead
their experience of 2019 was that he
could not do the job of being pm
properly
as soon as the election happened his
girlfriend
his girlfriend started trying to replace
key people
with incompetent studies so she could
run things
from the flat that is this is this is
quote she also had very strong opinions
on the imminent reshuffle
but she heavily and in my opinion wrong
way influence
after the reshuffle was supposedly
finished and the pm went upstairs
she insisted on reopening it and the pm
started calling around frantically from
the flat at midnight
appointing ministers and shuffling
people who had already
supposedly been finalized causing chaos
for poor officers downstairs
who could hear a shouting at him through
a phone
this awful environment he was ranting on
about how he was now the king
and doing mad things like trying to
organize obviously a legal secret
donations to pay for the flat
innovations and stuff like that
i'll need to stop you brian because of
the hour because we've got to go the
news uh in respect of dominic cummings
let me merely repeat the words
of another harlot mandy rice
davis who said in court
when told that one of her
clients was claiming something about her
she answered he would say that
wouldn't he and that has passed into
folklore for a good reason
you must always examine what reason
someone would have to say something bad
about someone else what that all added
up to
that you just quoted to me was dominic
cummings complaining
that the prime minister was listening
more
to his girlfriend now wife than she was
listening to
him he had no more
authority to give advice to the prime
minister
than she did he's unelected
she's unelected it's the prime minister
that carries the can
about what advice he takes
at the end of the day what advice he
implements i care nothing for dominic
cummings
or for mrs johnson
i care less for the prime minister
boris johnson i wish a plague on all of
their
houses but what you've just quoted to me
brian is tittle tattle
it's neither here nor is it
there what minister got appointed
as a result of whose advice
one elected person unelected person
or another unelected person doesn't add
up to
a row of beans no one will remember
in five years nevermind 50 who the
parliamentary under secretary for paper
clips
was in the boris johnson reshuffle
of 2019.
my problem is this i believe
that none of the front bench
politicians on either side of the house
is up to the challenge that faces
great britain and its great people
in this era that we are about to
enter the government is not fit for
purpose the opposition is not fit for
purpose
the prime minister's not fit for purpose
the leader of the opposition is not fit
for
purpose that's a much bigger problem
than who said what to whom in which
bedroom of downing street number 10
or number 11. i'm three minutes late
in going to jamie lowe for the news i do
so now
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news
large events with thousands of
spectators such as football matches
could be open
only to fully vaccinated people from
october
and the uk government plans talks are
underway with england's premier league
to discuss whether supporters who have
not received both jabs could be
barred from entry according to the pa
news
agency the rule could be also used for
lower divisions and other sports
and for other seated events with a
capacity more than 20
000 people for unseated events such as
gigs the threshold could be as low
as 5 000 attendees a government source
said it's important
that fans can continue to watch sporting
events over the autumn
which is why we're exploring the role
vaccines might play in this this will
not only allow full capacity stadiums
but
has the added bonus of incentivizing
people of all ages
to go and get their job crime and
policing minister kip malthouse did not
deny that the government was considering
vaccine passports for large events a uk
government minister has apologized to
those who've experienced delays at the
uk's airports over the weekend
people have complained of total chaos at
airports as summer holidays began for
millions
two hour long queues to show covert 19
documentation before boarding being
allowed airside were reported at
heathrow on
saturday while there were complaints of
a lack of staff at stansted airport
causing chaotic scenes airports and
airlines were expecting their busiest
weekend of the year
with hundreds more flights and thousands
more passengers than at any time during
the covert 19 pandemic
crime and policing minister kit
malthouse apologized for the delays
and suggested that airline staff could
be among those made exempt from having
to isolate if identified as a closed
contact
of someone who test positive for
coronavirus
australian politicians have condemned
protests against coronavirus
restrictions amid a rising cases
thousands marched through sydney
yesterday to demand an
end to lockdown measures with smaller
demonstrations taking place in melbourne
and brisbane
at least 57 people involved in the
sydney protest have been charged while
more than 500
have been fined the state recorded 141
new infections on sunday
the second highest daily increase of the
year there are fears of a further rising
cases following saturday's protests
some 30 million australians are being in
lockdown
after state governments reimpose
restrictions in recent weeks
to combat the highly contagious delta
variant which has driven up cases across
the country
fewer than 14 of the population have
been fully vaccinated
a far lower percentage than most
european countries and the us
a man woman and child have died and a
seven-year-old boy has been left
fighting for his life after getting into
difficulty in the water on loch lomond
in scotland
police scotland was called to reports of
concerns for people's safety in the
water near pulpit rock on saturday
evening
at about 6 40 p.m a 41 year old man a 29
year old woman and a nine-year-old boy
were pronounced dead at the scene while
another boy
seven was taken to intensive care at the
royal hospital for children in glasgow
where he remained
five people have died in the past 24
hours in scotland
after getting into trouble in water
belgium has been hit by floods in the
second time in just
over a week the provinces of namu and
walum brabant
southeast of the capital city of
brussels were among the worst hit after
thunderstorms and heavy rain reached the
country
on saturday in dainan in the walloon
region heavy rainfall washed away cars
leaving them strewn across the town
deputy mayor robert klossett said no
deaths or injuries had been reported
but the floods were worse than last
week's kidnappers in nigeria have seized
a man who was sent to deliver a ransom
payment to secure the release of dozens
of abducted school children
the elderly man was sent by children's
parents after they managed to raise 30
million
naira that's around 53 000 pounds by
selling land and other possessions
the north of the country is in the midst
of a wave of school abductions carried
out by criminals for profit
ransoms are frequently paid but this is
a rare case where the person carrying
the cash
has also been taken the kidnappers
called up the school's headteacher to
say that the money delivered was not the
agreed
sum the 136 students were taken from an
islamic school
in tajin and niger state in late may the
u.s government has requested to keep ann
serkulis's job a secret in the harry
dunn damages case due to
national security concerns the 19 year
old's parent charlotte charles and tim
dunn traveled to the u.s last month to
pursue a civil case
against his alleged killer sakulas as
well as her husband
jonathan harry died in august 2019 after
being struck off his motorbike by
sucoulas
who was driving her car on the wrong
side of the road near
raf crouton in northamptonshire both she
and her husband are believed to work for
the u.s
intelligence services
and finally norwegians have been left
awestruck by what experts say was an
unusually large meteor that illuminated
the night sky
in the country's south east footed shows
powerful flashes of light over norway
followed by what witnesses described as
loud bangs earlier today
norwegian police say they received a
flurry of emergency calls but there were
no reports of injuries or damage
a team of experts are hunting the meteor
which they believe landed in a forest
near the capital oslo
the norwegian meteor network says
today's fireball was visible for at
least five seconds
after it appeared at about 1am local
time traveling at about 36
500 miles per hour the meteor could be
seen over large parts of the southern
scandinavia region the network says
norwegian astronomer vegard recker said
his wife was awake at the time and she
could hear shaking
in the air before an explosion she
assumed something heavy
was falling near the house initial
research suggests the meteor may have
hit ground in a woodland area called
fine marker about 60 kilometers
west of oslo and that's the latest here
on sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
so the second poll of the evening is
slightly surreal
is joe biden senile
a clearly b arguably
see who am i well
the fact that we even have to ask that
question
of the man who holds the codes
to thousands of thermonuclear weapons
one or two of which could bring to an
end
life on this planet is slightly
troubling
who better to ask than a man with the
sharpest
eye in political journalism in the
united states
it's my old friend garland nixon garland
i didn't i didn't write that poll
and maybe it's not in the best of taste
i say to protect myself
but the fact that such discussions are
going on
particularly over in europe i don't know
what it's like maybe you're more polite
in the united states but as jimmy
doreputa your president
is a walking deathrattle
where do you stand on this is this elder
abuse
putting this man in this position or are
we all misunderstanding him
well there are a couple of things here
this is not just elder abuse this is
abuse of
an entire nation an entire society by
putting a man in a position that
basically embarrasses himself
embarrasses impart his his party and
embarrasses the country but it exposes
the reality of this
corporate oligarchy in which we live joe
biden
we knew everyone knew prior to his
election that he was not
um you know mentally prepared to hold
to hold the position of president of the
united states but what became even more
obvious was that the the powerful
oligarchs who run this country you know
we're always talking about russian
oligarchs or ukrainian oligarchs but
you know the people in america who run
things are just billionaires we can't
use such a pejorative term for those
gentlemen
but what we find is that job
a joe biden is precisely what they want
someone who is a hollow and empty suit
let me read from you really quick this
is from joe biden's town hall
he said quote and the question is
whether or not we should be in a
position
where our why can't the experts say we
know that this virus
is in fact it's going to be or excuse we
know why all the drugs approved are not
temporary
temporarily approved and but permanently
approved
that's underway too that was joe biden
ostensibly according to the oligarchs in
america the leader of the quote
free world staggering
i wish we could put those words uh up on
the screen or even the video
of it one video after another after
another
shows the man to be really in a parlor
state which
has to mean that the vice president is
really
calling the shots now i read that she's
tanking in the opinion polls
she might not even win the primary
to succeed uh joe biden
she didn't win a single delegate
when running for office herself
she is a creature of pure patronage
she was plucked blocked i said
from the crowd of uh
potential uh vp candidates
uh and given that position precisely
because
she doesn't actually stand for very much
she's a
she's really a blank piece of paper
isn't she
yes and she is a perv to me she is a
perfect example of the reality of the
the neo-liberal identity slash diversity
politics
where she checked all the boxes except
the boxes
of competence except the boxes of
ability
she checked the boxes that don't count
if you were if you just needed to vote
on a candidate based on a picture of the
candidate well there you go she looks
good
she occasionally sounds good however
when it comes to her ability to connect
with people
it is not um she has none when it comes
to her ability to address
policy competently she has none and
that's not to say that she's
that's not to address her intellect i'm
sure she's a brilliant person she
graduated from law school with good
grades etc
but when it comes to her ability to have
some connection
with the common man and woman to
understand their needs and to have any
drive whatsoever to address their needs
that is obviously absent and
she doesn't even have the ability to
fool people i would argue that donald
trump while
he was you know a they called him the
blue-collar billionaire simply because
he was
able to fool the working class into
thinking that he had their concerns
um you know in mind she's she's just
another
you know puppet for the billionaires and
she doesn't even have the ability to
fool people
and i think the um the people behind her
the people who are running the party who
stuck her in there
are aware of that and i think the
rumblings that we're hearing about her
is in reality um an indicator that
they're starting to
look for a way out they know that
calamity is at hand
if they run the likes of one uh kamala
harris in 2024.
yeah i mean if she was to stand against
donald trump in 2024
my money would be on trump beating her
well here's the thing about it not just
donald trump
who couldn't beat camel harris she could
not defeat
anyone in her own party in the primaries
she didn't get a single uh she didn't
get a
single uh uh delegate it would be like
taking someone
who was on a high who couldn't make a
high school soccer team
and trying to put them on a professional
soccer team as a as the
you know the star as a as a starter
she's she was completely unable
to um perform in
professional politics and they stuck her
at the
very top of the i'll put it like this
they
used her to give the appearance
the illusion that she was at the top of
the power structure
and that's the problem what we're
looking at in america
with joe biden with cameron harris is
the same thing
the illusion of power the illusion that
they're presiding over the united states
and their their that this team of
incompetence
just makes it clearer to everyone now
that they are in charge of nothing
now uh trump's not gone away
uh whether he'll last till 24 i'm not so
sure
but he hasn't gone away and he's slowly
uh targeting his enemies isn't he he's
now
uh put the black spot as
uh as was said in uh in treasure island
he delivered the black spot to uh uh
the daughter of uh of dick cheney
uh who was one of his persecutors in
chief in his own
party he's going to do whatever it takes
to destroy her
to replace her as the republican nominee
uh in in in her state
he's going through his enemies siri atom
now on one level that's quite
entertaining to see
uh you know i not really
much concerned who wins between donald
trump and
liz cheney uh i wish they both could
lose
um but on another level it
shows an obsession on the part of donald
trump with settling the scores
of last time which my instinct tells me
will not be enough to be a presidential
candidate in 24.
where do you stand on that i don't know
about that you know
i don't estimate don't underestimate
donald trump anymore for this reason
donald trump had one thing that he does
well as
for many of us he's not the most likable
person in the world and many of us can
see through
donald trump however he has a way of
finding people that are
far easier to hate than he is so when
cnn or msnbc attacked donald trump and
you know used their sanctimonious moral
positions to tell us how bad donald
trump was
people realized well we hate you far
worse than we hate donald trump
when he goes after um
any of the anyone with the last name
cheney who's remotely connected to dick
cheney or
or the bush administration he knows this
no
my name could be anything i don't exist
i have found people that are far
easier to hate than me that people see
as a gigantic threat so i think
one of the gifts as it were of donald
trump is finding people who are
who are more disliked who are more hated
who are more representative of a crash
system
than he is and even reminding people
when people say well donald trump you
know he
skated through the system and didn't pay
taxes he'll remind people
these are the people that created the
system in which i didn't have to pay
taxes
so i don't underestimate donald trump
only because i live in a system where
there are people
who can be easily um pointed out
as worse than donald trump and easier to
dislike than he than he than he
well that's a brilliant answer i'll make
a brilliant clip uh
you might have been talking about nancy
pelosi
uh whose personal wealth
has to say multiplied would be to
understate it
it has exponentially increased
in the long period in which she sat in
u.s
government um because she's married to
a guy who benefits mightily from
the inevitable pillow talk with mrs
pelosi in the evening times
these other people telling us that
donald trump is rotten
yes and additionally here's another big
problem the democratic party is going to
have and that is
they i mean you know they pretend as
though they won in some kind of a
landslide
as as though america chose them over
donald trump because donald trump was so
terrible and they were so great when in
reality
they barely slipped by donald trump by
the skin of their teeth
and they dragged along the left they
dragged along progressives mainly
because they said you've got to vote for
us because trump is so bad and many of
them believed it
that's not happening next time around um
they have been exposed
after the uh after they won by the skin
of their teeth and might i had they
actually lost houses in the seat and
they barely
barely won the senate and lost um
through
in many of the state houses after that
they turned on those same progressives
that they had asked to
to come along with them and said well we
would have won more the
the the reason we didn't do better is
because of you so i suspect
in 2022 and 2024 um number one in 2022
trump will not be there and i expect the
democrats to get pounded pretty bad
um but in 20 and 2022 but in 2024
um people the the um progressives
in the party the left flank of the party
will have either left the party or said
you know we've been down that road one
time
and uh you can go ahead and pull this
one off when you're on your own and i
suspect
we will see what we see in america every
eight years and that is every
four to eight years whichever party is
neo-liberal
war party is in completely um
everything falls apart the people are
unhappy their lives are worse
and then they ping pong over to the
other party and then they get eight more
years of
you know of horribleness and i suspect
that come
2024 will go back over to the
republicans and they'll do a
fantastically miserable job of screwing
everything up
now speaking of which how is the u.s
economy doing
well you know there are a lot of things
going on right now and that is
we are in a period of time where the um
the uh uh the laws that prevented
um uh landlords from evicting people
is about to end and so while the u.s
economy
seems to be moving ahead you know fairly
decently
we have high inflation which means that
people are having trouble paying their
bills
and we're about to have some kind of an
eviction um apocalypse which i suspect
will have a significantly a
significantly negative
impact on our economy let's not forget
we are also facing a horrible situation
out west where we've got wildfires
we've got a um you know unthinkable heat
110 degrees 120 degrees all over the
place
and what's not being discussed is the
spring wheat harvest is predicted
as a result of the drought and the um
the the the the heat our spring wheat
harvest
is predicted to be 41 lower
than 2020 so i suspect we will soon be
seeing
as a result of the drought we're going
to be seeing food prices
um california this the there's a huge
fertile valley in the center in the
center of california it's like 450 miles
long and 60 miles wide
but it's in the midst of the drought and
heat as food prices continue
to rise and make it much worse and food
may get make it considerably more scarce
let's just say things don't look good
for the near future in the united states
we'll keep a close eye on that latter
point especially garland nixon thanks as
always
for joining us on the mother of all talk
shows
is joe biden senile clearly 66
arguably 19 who am
i 15 i did tell you it was slightly
uh surreal let's take some calls danny
in new jersey
go ahead danny hi
uh george i'm a u.s citizen i
a absolutely a poor or aggressive uh
posture that we consistently take in
south america cuba
africa especially the middle east but
even china
and but the problem that
we individuals face is that both our
major political parties
uh are pro-war
so my my question is what can an
individual do to most
effectively exact change in our foreign
policy
well of course you can be active on
issues
and in campaigns that are not directly
party political but you can't go on uh
in a political system where
the two parties are two cheeks of the
same
ass you you you have to
create something new we have a similar
situation
here although these two cheeks
are less popular together
and separately than they have ever been
when i was first in politics i kid you
not
98 of the people voted for
one cheek or the other cheek now that
is well less than 50 percent and
falling uh of course the downside to
that
is that the number of people voting for
nobody
uh has uh increased steadily
over that period but i'm one of these
who
says the the united states and britain
needs a third party needs a party that
stands up for working people uh
excuse uh the big money oligarchies
and stands up for peace
instead of war i would have thought
there's a market in your country
as i think there is here for such a
party
well i mean uh barack obama was elected
based on that anti-war sentiment that he
that he preached yeah i mean it was all
alive of course hurting him
to watch his foreign policy unwind and
then you know trump came in
it was it was all a lie uh he was just a
good
crooner a schmoozer but he
he was he to say was a disappointment
would be
severely to understated he was a
betrayer
of the hopes of tens of millions of
people that backed him
based on what he seemed to be but
he is what he is because he is
or was the leader of one of these two
parties that i've characterized thus
so what does an individual do well you
should be involved
i know lots of people in new jersey very
good friends of mine
uh there are all kinds of campaigns
going on
in your state uh that are worth
participating in and they don't involve
supporting either the democrats or the
republicans
and i believe uh for what it's worth i'm
a
i'm a foreigner but i believe that
the people's party in the united states
will have to be built will have to
emerge
danny thanks for the call arya is in
vancouver
let's hear from arya go ahead
hello george welcome
thank you i wanted to talk about
something
special tonight that's the united nation
and the fact that it's not democratic
and the fact that nobody cares including
intellectuals
i never hear any intellectual or anybody
else for that matter to talk about this
fact that this united
nation is not democratic it's not
supposed to be like this
is supposed to bring
arya isn't our silence eloquent enough
we don't talk about it because well we
don't talk about it because
it is of zero importance it's a complete
house
so important how is it that this is the
most urgent task for every human on
earth in my opinion
and it is zero importance to you i don't
get it i'll tell you why it's zero
importance to me
because it is the best definition
of something that is literally
unreformable
irrecoverable you simply
cannot not on a thousand dollars
you could not in a thousand years
reform the united nations why
because you would have to get the votes
to reform it
of the people who have everything to
gain
and everything to lose by
keeping it the way it is the
permanent five with their veto
powers would have to
agree to abolishing
their own permanent status
and veto status and
even just one of them exercising that
veto
would kill any possibility
of reform so why bother
about an organization that is literally
unchangeable last word to you are there
george i was in grade seven
for the first time i heard about this um
and this is society
by my teacher this system of
veto power for five sounded ridiculous
then
as a testing 14 year old boy it sounds
ridiculous to steal
of course it's criminal but you don't
you'd have to get all five of them
if i if i can understand it at 13 how is
it that
other people don't understand it doesn't
matter whether they do it
arya it doesn't matter whether everybody
in the world
understood it it simply cannot be
changed
the united a new one well that's another
one you need something
organization i'm here with i'm with you
on
on that one my friend but it's simply
a fool's errand to go about
campaigning for the reform of the united
nations
it is literally impossible
thanks for that call from the great city
of
vancouver now uh i missed a question
no time to ask it so here's the last one
the first football world cup final took
place
this week in 1930
1930 who won a
argentina b brazil c
uruguay answers after the break
[Music]
it has filled our hospitals it has
killed
400 doctors nurses
and care home professionals friends of
mine
have died of it so what exactly are you
on here
telling me that it's not infectious
i i'm not sure tell us what you think
don't be coy roy
right well i'm gonna quote um doctor
and he said that the pandemic was over a
long time ago
in a video an unlocked video and and
it's going around right now you know you
can
watch you guys are always doing your
research on the internet
look okay
you see you have got a point of view you
are being coy roy
you you you come on here playing the
daft lady
i just saw something on the government's
website
something i can choose between ben
in hull on youtube or
i can trust the doctors and the medical
authorities can trust them
or i can go with we ben i mean i'm not
we've been on youtube on the good
website
what are you saying tell us look you
started out by saying covid
was not an infectious uh disease
are you really saying that probably are
you really saying
that ben stop being silly
are you really saying this is that the
corona virus
i'm repeating what has been stated on
the government website
i already explained to you that it was
otherwise
thus classified it is a public health
emergency
aren't you aware of it don't you know
the cost we
paid of it don't you know how many
people have died
how many people are sick how many
doctors and nurses
are dead now in the cold earth
fighting something that you're on the
radio
telling me doesn't exist i have no
longer any
patience for this kind of
juvenile nonsense
[Music]
radio sputnik
the mother of all talk shows with george
galloway
the world is our classroom and you're
welcome to sit in and join the seminar
now the answer to my question is one of
the miraculous phenomena
in the world of football uruguay won the
world cup in 1930.
do you know the population of uruguay
the population of uruguay then
was less than 2 million in now
is not much more than 2 million
yet they've won the world cup twice
there's something miraculous
about that patrick christie's there is
it who joins me now
uh what are they doing right that other
small countries like my own
are not doing thanks for uh for joining
us
as always uh i know you're now an
extremely busy man and i hope that
uh continues uh let's talk media first
um i was amazed to discover
that although i'm paying them for how
much longer i don't know
a bbc license fee in part because
i could watch things like the olympic
games on it
all day and all sports
actually i can't they were outbid by the
discovery
channel and now have highly restricted
access to it yeah how did the bbc
fail to secure their as long as i've
been alive
their traditional role as the best
people to bring you the olympic games
yeah i think it's twofold i think first
and foremost there's bbc arrogance the
second thing is i think they tend to put
personalities in my opinion and often
bang average personalities ahead of
actual
output right so dealing with the first
one first i think they thought that they
could just off whatever
and the people in charge are giving the
rights to the olympic games will go well
it's the bbc
well that reputation has gone the old
school idea of it's the bbc it's fact
it's proper it's proper television
that's out the window now because you've
got the likes of the streamers and
you've got the likes of your disney's in
et cetera like that
and disney basically stumped up a load
of cash 390 million quid
if we believe what's what's in the
papers now the bbc have obviously
decided that they felt as though they
couldn't compete with that financially
but
reputation alone might be able to give
them that and that wasn't the case and
now a lot of
complaints have been gone in because
actually people are thinking well i'm
gonna admit you're only allowed to show
one sport at a time
you used to be able to press that famous
red button and see anything from the
pole vault or whatever and it was great
it was fantastic
the other thing is the likes of paying
zoey ball a heck of a ton of money too
as far as i can see
lose you about 500 000 listeners and say
things like that's a nice song up next
here's another lovely song
i don't quite understand why they're
doing that you might see gary linekers
of this world as well
as long as you're paying talent so
quotes and quotes talent that amount of
money
and you therefore haven't got the money
to do other things as well
then that's an issue i think the bbc
fundamentally is feeling the pinch and i
think that it's a representation of the
market as it is
it's almost capitalism in action really
in a sense yeah i don't mind that
i mean uh i i do it already i pay
bt i pay sky sports
i pay mu tv uh because they've all got
the rights to things that i want to see
i even watched united get humped by
queen's park rangers
last night and watched the after match
interviews
that's how much of a glutton for
punishment i am
but the bbc is not capitalism i
am forced to pay the bbc yeah or i will
go to prison
yeah and so if i'm going to be forced
i expect it at least to deliver its
reputational age-old
traditional role of royal weddings and
funerals and the olympic games and the
fa cup final and so on what do you use
to get the cricket on there as well
didn't you you see a lot of this stuff
and you've lost all that and that's a
very good point that george because the
other thing that we also expect the bbc
to do as well which i would argue that
they're not doing
is to give us a proper and biased news
service so when you really look at it in
the round right
what are you getting for your money now
if you pay the bbc license fee as you
say
on pain of prison right so you're
guessing i would argue exceptionally
buyer's news coverage a lot of the time
slanted one way or the other certainly
not all the time that accurate the
amount of time that they have people on
there who turn out to be activists for a
particular party
the amount of time that when you do a
particular report especially the run up
to an election
and you see who's on the production
staff of that report they turn out to
have links to various different parties
etc etc so the news service at its core
is not okay in fact i would argue that
it's rotten i think you look at the kind
of sporting elements of it
the pageantry of the sporting elements
that the bbc supposedly do quite well
well now they're losing out there as
well and then you look at okay well are
they giving us entertainment well
some things like peaky blind as i would
argue is pretty good they do
give you the odd thing killing e
fantastic stuff okay but they also give
you
programs a six-part documentary on
britain's longest road and i don't think
that's particularly great value for
money
well i can't wait to watch that one
myself this goes on for ages
speaking of talent um
gb news we talked about it last week
yeah yeah made a bad start yeah
their answer is najo
is that the answer well it's certainly
been the answer so far and you can't
you know nigel gives you time to give
you numbers and actually he's also quite
an underrated broadcaster whether or not
people agree with his politics
that's one thing entirely but actually
he's very good at his job and he's
he's a consummate professional as well
despite this kind of image of this hard
drinking large socializing chat but he
is all of those things of course but
he's also very good on television and
radio and whatever job you give him to
do
and so yes i think he massively is uh
moving the right direction
i can fully understand why they didn't
go for him initially because it was too
stereotypical right
gb news let's launch the nigel farage
show right it writes itself so i think
there was initial kind of bit of
let's give him some time um so gb news i
think clearly is is there's changes of
foot aren't there really and i think
that
it seems to be moving in in the right
direction in that sense there is a
market there for
it it's whether or not they get that
right there's definitely a market
for uh for an alternative to the bbc
even an alternative to sky which really
shares
most of the prevailing assumptions of
the bbc
hatred of brexit uh often
sounds like looks like a hatred of the
country
the hatred of the people in the country
anyway who stubbornly refused
to go along with their liberal agenda
definitely a market for it uh do you
think though that
they've having having invested all this
money
that the owners might now be having
second thoughts or are they
in blood so steeped is it bloodier to go
on or to go
i don't see how you can walk away from
it at this particular juncture at the
end of the day there's a startup there
and there's by any stretch of the
imagination startup is going to have
difficulties i think we can all name a
couple of other startups i mean i've
worked for a couple for example
where things have not even got off to
this good start i think one of the
reasons perhaps why they lost as early
as they did was more due to commercial
pressures and one can understand that
it's an expensive business having to
set up and start and run a corporation
of the science of gb news
i think it's a credit to gb news and to
the staff involved into everyone there
in the management that they've managed
to have a go as much as they have so far
and i think realistically the only way
is up and i do think as well like you've
just said that
the pure fact of the matter is that the
british public and it's to a massive
credit to the british public
that in the face of an onslaught of i
would argue media bias and political
class bias establishment bias and all
this
actually time and time well not time
telling especially the the eu referendum
we stood up and we were counted and we
weren't swayed by that so can you
imagine
what actually happens if you're
presented with a news channel that
speaks for you or certainly speaks more
for you than
the establishment media yeah interesting
now on the political front
it looks to me that boris cannot get his
coveted passport through in the house
yeah i think he's uh he's going to lose
that vote
if uh if uh
performs as he presumably will
opportunistically yeah there's enough
rep well this is the thing isn't it
there's enough rebels to defeat boris
well this is the thing
it would be nice if the person voting
against kobe passports had some kind of
principled skin in the game he doesn't
he's obviously being a chancellor about
it however i also think it's
great that he's doing it right because
i'm i'm a person personally speaking i'm
a person over here passports
and i find it absolutely staggering that
we have this supposedly libertarian
prime minister who actually at no point
really in his political life has ever
shown you that he's a libertarian
particularly
he's just done some stuff like the mayor
of london and things like that
celebrated the olympics there needs to
be a libertarians get stuck on a zip
wire right
so and and so now now we're in a
situation where unless we have some tory
rebels it's not a very shrewd thing by
the way the likes of
your michael goes and your jacob reese
mogs who you would imagine would
currently be doing some serious damage
from the back benches well they're in
the fold now aren't they right so they
can't be the vocal people speaking out
they can't be whipping up the 1922
committee in the way that they would
normally be doing
so we're relying on the rebels of which
we believe there might be about 40.
we're then also reliant obviously on
labour and the lib dems etc
and so there's a chance that it will go
through one of the issues i have with
kierstahler is that he's against the
kobe passports at least he is for now
he does as far as i'm concerned have a
spine made of cooked spaghetti and
therefore there's a bit of an issue with
that whether or not we actually see this
one through
blamange in fact let's take some uh
calls
uh dan in liverpool go ahead dan
hello yes dan you're welcome go ahead
hey father no problem um i just want to
ask
like what what's your um opinion on
the current labour party i mean you know
you would labor and
friends with neglect states and all that
and i don't mean to use that
disingenuously but
how do you see labor ever winning my
and i don't want them ever to win i wish
later
i wish labour perdition uh but let's
hear what patrick thinks
the labour party you in a way just
summed it up
it's led by a man uh with the moral
principles of a of a jellyfish yeah
absolutely we've got a labor party at
the moment we're led by a bloke who's
not done as a common courtesy of telling
us what he thinks about anything which
is a bit of an issue right so when
you're going to be asked to vote we saw
it at the local elections where labour
got served and we've seen it at numerous
times as well
actually i think it's catastrophic and i
think it's insulting the idea that
you're not actually telling us what it
is you want to vote for i'm not i'm not
against the labour party what i am
saying is a matter of kind of democratic
principle
if you stand for elections i mean people
fought and died for the right to vote
right well they've fallen down for the
right to choose you've seen who to vote
for and at the moment you can't choose
you to vote for because kirsten was not
telling you what it is you're voting for
i've heard that kirsten is spending a
lot of money on
focus groups to try to get a handle on
what the public opinion is
that's the concern for a bloke whose job
relies on standing for public election
every few years you should be in touch
with the public thing
and actually by and large especially the
more than being general here
the more working class areas that labour
frankly needs to win right you need to
support this country
you need to back the queen you need to
kind of be proud of the flag sing the
national anthem don't take the knee in
my opinion and kirsten does the opposite
of all of those things or at least seems
to be in part
well it could be worse dan could be uh
don butler she
her maneuvers this week were quite
obviously
uh a teeing up of a of a future
leadership challenge how would don
butler play in the country do you think
dan why are the labour party failed so
miserably i mean you understand what
neoliberalism is right
i mean you you were a part kind of
of that time i just want to understand
like
why well the labour party has fallen out
of love
uh with the british people and the
british people have
reciprocated the labour party wants to
infatuate fetishize uh identity politics
of
race and sex and gender and everything
except
class yeah but don't don't you think
labour had some parts of playing that
though
with the whole classism thing i mean
like you're supposed to be old labor
right you run against
new labor if there's a commerce so i
think it's on people like you
to promote actual policies
no why should i break like what do
or whatever i think the labour party is
a
catastrophic disaster yeah there's
something about it then
why why are you complaining about it why
don't you do something about it
instead of complaining it's like
everyone wants to complain the left
is that's my friend well i'm not
going to pardon it uh
but dan obviously doesn't know that i'm
actually the leader of
a rival political party and stand
against the labour party
in in elections uh let's hear from
andrew in cleveland in the u.s
go ahead andrew hey i i'm an
organizer with a group called action for
assange or uh
decentralized global protest network
that's been working to secure julian's
freedom for the last
two plus years now yeah um so first of
all i just want to say i appreciate your
unyielding support of him
um you've been someone that's always
done a great job speaking out
on his behalf so thank you it's my duty
it's my duty to do so
well one of the things that we do um
because we do a regular show on youtube
just keeping people up to date on the
information in julian's case
um one of the things we do is we go
through the numbers and it's a
date since important it's the time past
since important dates so we have 3876
days
of illegal and arbitrary detention for
julian assange
um it's been 840 days since the
wikileaks founder was trafficked from
the ecuadorian embassy after being sold
to the us in the uk
for a 4.2 billion dollar loan from the
international monetary fund to
lenin moreno's ecuadorian government
we have 203 days since vanessa
bereitzer's january 6 ruling denying
julian assange bail
after personally ordering his release
and ruling no extradition in his case
and we have um just as an example of
what happens here in the united states
um 1433 days of inhumane pre-trial
detention
for a not even proven whistleblower
joshua schultz
of the about seven weeks um and 985 of
those days
minimum have been spent in special
administrative measures which is a
heinous heinous type of lockdown
the us injustice system is
infamous throughout the world thanks
andrew for that
uh call it is a bit funny if you don't
mind me saying patrick that all
these libertarian journalists and
broadcasters never seem to find time to
mention
that there's a guy rotting in in
belmarsh
for publishing yeah absolutely and in
fact there was not more made of the fact
that in this country
right now this very government is trying
to actively pass a law
that if you leak as a journalist if you
leak anything that comes from you from
within a government department
you could face 14 years in prison so for
example whoever it may have been
who dished out the matt hancock stuff
right they could now under this law
before
14 years of bird right i mean it's a lot
right it's a lot by anyone
you have to turn anyone right so you
think well actually this is this is
britain this is supposedly the home one
of the homes of democracy one of the
homes in western democracy
and we've got a government at the moment
that not only on top of that also wants
to stand for your rights to protest
i actually had an albanian cab driver
right the other day he said that as a
condition of his
uh right to remain in this country if he
was ever found
attending what was deemed to be an
illegal gathering or an illegal protest
he could have his citizenship removed
well it's only illegal if the government
calls it illegal right and they've
passed laws that now could make
basically
anything they want illegal so it's a
rigged game right and so we're in a
situation
now not only where we have this this
literally criminal situation with with
assange right but we also have a
situation where frankly
if a minister passed me something or
anyone passed me something
that could have happened it could happen
indeed that exposes someone right
at the top of government doing something
catastrophically awful that we all need
to know about
i could go to jail for 14 years for that
and that has to be wrong
on that subject um k karma
says this is the injustice that needs
airing the julian assange case
although i guess it wouldn't help your
viewing ratings eh
question mark are you actually
insane there is no
program anywhere on any media
anywhere in the entire world that has
showcased the julian assange issue
more than this one there is no frontline
political person in this country
done more to highlight the julian
assange case
than me the public sometimes uh
amazes me richard is in manchester go
ahead richard
good evening george thanks for having me
on thank you patrick um
at the end of the at the end of the day
george um i hope
that this this week will bring you some
uh karma with regards to julian assange
because
he's got an appeal going doesn't he on
thursday i think yes
we we very much hope that uh julian will
finally be
released we very much regret
that the incoming u.s government of joe
biden
has not dropped the case uh that
it's unconscionable that julian might
spend
several years uh untried unconvicted
in belmar prison uh when he could have a
tag on
uh and be under uh home
detention while his uh while his case is
uh
is determined and i couldn't agree more
with you george
the judge has already decided he
shouldn't be extradited
so that the onus is on the person doing
the appealing
patrick when you look at some of the
people that we do have out walking the
streets now and
and one of the great examples those are
really harrowing topic this is some of
the grooming guns companies have had in
this country right
there are people there who've committed
you know some of the most obvious things
you can do
who've now been in prison for maybe
something like two and a half years and
been allowed back out
into the same town where their victims
still live and then you've got julian
assange you
publish stuff that we all just needed to
know about right
and this is a guy now he's fronting up
to well what is he fronting up to
rotting in a jail cell
indefinitely until you know some
political powers signed i mean that's
just not right that just doesn't make
any sense right no
and that is a journalist and yet most
journalists
seem completely uninterested is amazing
shortly to hario richard because
there's a legend on the line it's norma
in bristol go ahead norma
hello george and patrick um you are
watching the olympics
i'm sure of that well i am because
to be honest it's a pleasant diversion
the thing is
george i watched the opening ceremony
and it was a bit long
but i'm an internationalist so they
think you are
and i left seeing all the hundreds of
nations with their flags
and then at one point one point they
played
john lennon's imagine i don't know if
you heard it but it was quite
moving yeah so that started me off quite
well he said
it wasn't wrong and then i was thinking
well
there's all these contestants in the
various sports they've worked so hard
last year was cancelled and i just
enjoy watching especially the athletics
and the gymnasts
um it's a shame that there's nobody in
the stadiums but you see
ira and japan should have badly
organized themselves they should have
organized
more to be populated and vaccinated yeah
but
the problem the problem is norma the
vast majority of the japanese public
don't want it
to be happening because they're scared
of the virus the nature
yeah and they've they've not vaccinated
nearly enough people
it's just totally bad organization
really
but um going back to climate change
apparently there might be a very bad
storm where they're coming in the next
day or two so
god knows what's going to happen now
it's already uh hitting
central london patrick had to swim here
uh this evening
if he didn't he'll have to swim out uh
it
really is uh thanks norma for that
really is extremely
yeah i i didn't drink unexpected i
didn't bring an umbrella and i always
spent the last 10 minutes before coming
on air with my head under your hand
dryer in the toilets
so uh so that's that's something it
reminded me of being bullied at school
you know which obviously never happened
but
uh you know so you know it was it was
it's extreme weather
i do think it's a little long i don't
know where you sit on this but i do
think it's a little bit premature
everyone now points at this and goes
well look at climate change right i can
remember
terrible weather right when i was
younger yeah right before we were kind
of having this debate so
i think it's a little bit much to go now
oh well it's obviously i think well we
had someone on who i'm told there's a
fox news uh uh i didn't know that but a
fox news man
uh he didn't deny those climates yeah
yeah
uh we may have different views on how it
how it got here there have been extreme
weather events forever
yeah and there have been climate changes
forever
uh but he had some pretty sensible
points to
make we should all live a better life we
should all live a greener cleaner life
we should all invest in
infrastructure that can deal with floods
for example one of the problems
outside our door right now is that most
of london's
sewage was built in the victorian
era yeah and simply can't stand up to
the pressures yeah of uh these weather
changes no absolutely so we have an
infrastructure problem especially in a
city the size of london we do have
probably london we're simply not
designed certainly the transport system
in london was not designed for the
volume of people that
are using it now and etcetera etcetera
etcetera we all the volume of cyclists
yeah yeah but also i think you look at
the people who were supposedly the
leading examples of this you know your
likes of your prince harry's etcetera
well he thinks nothing about taking a
private jet
anywhere and when he gets out on that
private jet he gets in a you know a huge
diesel yeah diesel jugging car you know
sadiq khan rolls around in a car quite
regularly
yeah despite inflicting cycle lanes on
the rest of us and so you think about
actually
how genuine are the people in charge
about fighting climate change why do
people like you and i have to foot the
bill for it
this is the problem throughout that the
credibility of our rulers is
such that even when they're right
people don't believe them people doubt
them people question their
motives patrick wonderful to see you
again thank you very much for
joining us and thank you for joining us
on the
mother of all talk shows it's been
marvelous for me i hope it was for you
and if it was
please come back next week at the same
time and same place
with another listener don't forget the
podcast
and here's the poll result joe biden
is clearly see now 67 percent of you
two-thirds of you think joe biden the
president of the u.s
is clearly senile and 18
of you think it's at least arguable good
night
[Music]
you